Hallo, ist da wer?
Ja, ein Roboter.
Hallo du, bist du wirklich ein Roboter?
Ja, allerdings bin ich nur ein kleiner Roboter. Ja, klick, ich habe dich gesucht, weil ich ein paar wichtige technische Dinge mit dir besprechen muss. Sie sind auch für dich sehr wichtig.
Etwas technisches? Moment, ich bin gleich wieder da, ja?
Chaos Radio.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express Ausgabe Nummer 97. Am 16. August 2008 aufgenommen, also eigentlich schon vor der 96, aber ich weiß jetzt schon, dass die später gepostet wird. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und wie immer begrüße ich euch zu einer neuen Ausgabe hier von der Sendung aus dem Internet, die immer versucht alles Mögliche zu erklären, von dem man vorher schon gar nicht wusste, dass es das gab. Und heute möchte ich auch wieder in so ein Thema hineinbohren, von etwas, was jeder von uns schon mal benutzt hat, aber wo man eigentlich selten wirklich nachschaut, wie es wirklich funktioniert, was meistens daran liegt, dass man auch niemanden kennt, der es einem erklären kann. So ähnlich geht es mir auch. Allerdings habe ich jetzt nach nur 16 Jahren Forschungsarbeit geschafft, einen Experten hier an den Tisch zu kriegen. Und ich begrüße Jens-Uwe. Hallo. Jens-Uwe Mager, hallo. Ja, 16 Jahre habe ich erwähnt. So lange haben wir uns, glaube ich, nicht mehr gesehen.
Ja, kommt hin, 16 Jahre mussten es fast sein.
Mindestens, wir wissen es gar nicht mehr so ganz genau. Aber wie das immer so ist im Leben, die Kreise schließen sich dann irgendwann doch wieder. Und ja, so habe ich jetzt die Gelegenheit, den Jens-Uwe mal zu einem Thema auszufragen, in dem er sich in den letzten Jahren doch eine ganze Menge Expertise zugelegt hat. Es soll nämlich gehen um Fileserver-Protokolle, also die Sprache, die die Computer untereinander sprechen, um sich gegenseitig den Zugriff auf Dateien zu erlauben. Das ist ja heutzutage durchaus etwas Gängiges. Vor 20 Jahren war das noch nicht unbedingt jetzt so normal, dass man seinen Computer in Netzwerken drin hatte. Heutzutage lässt sich das ja eigentlich kaum noch vermeiden. Aber bevor wir vielleicht auf die Fileserver und ihre Protokolle und ihre Dateien und ihre Eigenarten eingehen, vielleicht nochmal kurz ein bisschen was zu dir. Du bist ja nun auch schon einer der Früheinsteiger mit Computern gewesen, oder? Wann fing das so bei dir an?
Ich glaube in den 70ern mit dem Kim-1 Einplatinencomputer von Commodore.
Das war auch so ein 65002-Gerät, oder?
Genau, so mit 1 KB ROM-Speicher und ein paar 100 bytes RAM.
Kim-1. Kim hatte wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal eine Tastatur, oder?
Hex-Tastatur und Hex-Anzeige. Und dann ein paar digitale Ausgänge zum Spielen.
Okay, das heißt du hast deinen Assembler einfach noch per Hex-Code geschrieben?
Ja, zuvor auf Papier assembliert und dann die bytes mal freigelassen, für die Branche aufsetzen und dann durchgezählt.
Und was hat denn der gekostet eigentlich damals? Das war bestimmt scheiße teuer, oder?
Ja, das war damals ziemlich teuer, aber ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern, muss ich jetzt passen.
Und dann bist du aber eigentlich auch gleich meine Bisse da jetzt, wie alt warst du da?
15, 16.
Also reines typisches jugendlichen Interesse sozusagen. Sowas brauche ich auch, Computer, damit fliegt man zum Mond.
Ja, das fing an mit Taschenrechnern, als man da anfing zu programmieren. Dann hat man gesehen, oh, man kann auch was mit steuern, vielleicht mit so einem kleinen Einplatinen-Computer. Und dann hat man gesehen, oh, es gibt auch Tastaturen und Bildschirme, mit denen man noch ein bisschen komfortabel mit dem Computer interagieren kann. Und dann ging es dann immer größer, je nachdem, was die Börse gerade hergegeben hat, die eigene.
Und wie ging das dann weiter?
Ja, es ging dann weiter mit einem iOS Scientific Challenger 1P, so ein Vorgänger vom PET 2001. Da hat ein frühes Microsoft Basic drin gehabt, von 650.02. Der war sehr buggy, der Microsoft-Unterpreter damals in dem Ding. Die Garbage Collection ging zwar, ich bin nicht. Dann kam es dann die zweite Zeit mit dem Apple II. Da war ich dann also ganz früh mit dabei und auch lange mit dabei. Und vom Apple II bin ich eigentlich direkt ohne große Umwege auf diverse CPM-Rechner gewechselt. Und von CPM dann auf UNIX. Der PC lief in der selben Zeit wie die CPM-Rechner und die UNIX-Rechner ein bisschen parallel, aber war nie so ganz mein Zuhause. Mein Zuhause war dann so ziemlich früh, so ab die 84 rum, eigentlich ständig UNIX.
Und mit welchem UNIX fing es da an? Damals gab es da noch nicht so viele UNIX.
Nee, das waren damals so, das war zum Beispiel von Conversion Technologies die 68.000 basierenden Maschinen. Die hatten so eine nette Mischung von 4.1 BSD und System 5, also sprich in System 5, was damals schon Paging hatte. Und das war schon eher später als sonst bei anderen UNIXen der Fall. Mit einem 68.000 Prozess, das waren nette Maschinen.
Aber auch teuer und groß.
Ja, die waren damals nicht für einen Privatmann erschwinglich, sondern die hat man dann irgendwo schon in einem kommerziellen Umfeld gefunden und hat man dafür dann gearbeitet.
Das heißt, da warst du dann auch schon als Programmierer tätig in der einen oder anderen Form?
Genau, da war ich dann also auch schon beschäftigt.
Convergent Technologies habe ich noch gar nicht gehört. Oder? 8086?
Nein, nicht 8086. Die hatten 8086-Rechner. Die Motorola-Dinger, die waren wirklich Convergent Technologies Miniframe eingekauft. Was dann zum Beispiel als Motorola 6300 verkauft wurde, waren dann wirklich Convergent Technologies Miniframe. Von denen kam das Betriebssystem. Motorola hat das nur als Second Source verkauft.
Ah, verstehe. So ein UEM-Provider.
Genau.
So, hier wir haben UNIX für euch. Damals ging das ja mit diesem UNIX auch noch wirklich wild her. Heute herrscht ja geradezu Monokultur mit den vier oder fünf populären Systemen, die so im Einsatz sind. Aber damals hat ja wirklich jeder Hersteller eigentlich so sein eigenes UNIX gemacht, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade so ein UEM-UNIX war.
Da gab es ja tausend Varianten. Also dieser wirkliche Wildwurst wie Pilz im Wald.
Aber UNIX hat dir gleich gefallen. Das war so dein Zuhause, ja?
Ja, das war so das System, mit dem man also sehr gut arbeiten konnte, dass es also diese Multi-User-Möglichkeit gab, viele Prozesse. Damals, zu der Anfangszeit, waren ja die meisten Betriebssysteme nur Single-User, also sprich ein User, eventuell vielleicht ein, zwei Programme offen mit den ersten grafischen Betriebssystemen, die damals aufkamen. Aber das war ja alles noch ein bisschen eher gefaked auf dem PC oder auf dem Mac und nicht wirklich. Multifiner kam ja später. Während UNIX hatte schon richtiges Multitasking.
Multifiner ist aber auch gefaked.
Ja, ich weiß, das kann sich noch entsinnen, wo man oben rechts in der Ecke klickte und das Ganze rauschte sozusagen das Bild.
Das ist klar, Multitasking hat sich auch nicht durchgesetzt. In der Zeit hatte ich ja meine ersten zarten UNIX-Erlebnisse mit so einem Xenix-System. Das war ja dann so die erste Möglichkeit, UNIX zu schnuppern auf einer PC-Plattform.
Genau.
Aber da gab es schon etwas vorher, nicht wirklich.
Vielleicht ein bisschen so das Minix-Zeug, das man auch mal herbekommen konnte.
Ja gut, aber das hat man dann mal einmal ausprobiert und dann hat man wieder was anderes gemacht. Das heißt, du bist mit UNIX verbundelt und wenn man halt viel UNIX macht, dann ist man natürlich auch schnell eigentlich auch in diesem, in dieser kleinen Serverdenke drin, hatte ich so den Eindruck immer. Also dieses Leben mit Hintergrundprozessen, mit irgendwie Programmen, die auf D enden, diese ganzen Dämonen und so, die irgendwie Dinge machen. Ich meine, allein so ein Erlebnis wie das Talk-Kommando, wo dann irgendwie man einfach mit dem einen und dem anderen User irgendwie miteinander kommunizieren kann. Also man ist einfach schon auf UNIX automatisch irgendwie vernetzt, dadurch, dass einfach noch andere Benutzer das System gleichzeitig benutzen, hatte ich immer das Gefühl, war das immer schon so ein bisschen wie Internet heute. Man ist einfach nicht mehr alleine auf dem Computer.
Genau, man ist also gleich von vornherein vernetzt. Die frühen UNIX-Varianten war es noch relativ einfach, aber sobald ein bisschen BSD-isches in dem UNIX drin war, war ja auch immer lokale Netzwerk-Komponenten möglich und man konnte ja auch innerhalb des Rechners ohne einen Netzwerkkabel schon richtiges Networking machen mit dem simulierten internen Local-House-Netzwerk, was ja heute auch jeder kennt.
Also BSD, deshalb, weil bei BSD TCP-IP im Prinzip das erste Mal kam?
Die BSD...
Ach so, die normalen Sockets ohne IP?
Damit kam die API für Netzwerkprogrammierung dazu, zum UNIX. Die haben die Berkeley Leute sich ausgedacht und im Zuge der abhandenen Implemation im UNIX auch eingebaut. Eine der großen Sachen, die eben von Berkeley kamen, in die UNIX-API rein. Und sobald dann die API drin war, waren dann auch lokal eine Möglichkeit, immer mit Programmen Netzwerkaktivitäten zu machen, auch wenn kein Kabel drin steckt. Man kann also kleine Server-Achitekturen mit dem Localhost, mit dem eingebauten 127.0.1-Netzwerk ausprobieren, ohne wirklich verkabelt zu sein.
Genau, oder auch einfach so mit normalen Sockets, ohne dass man jetzt noch IP wirklich dabei hat. Aber IP war ja dann im Prinzip auch immer mit dabei, oder?
Nee, das macht man meistens mit API meistens auch.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, in dem Moment, wo die Sockets da waren, gab es halt auch IP, weil dafür ist es irgendwie erfunden worden.
Genau.
Da schließt sich das ja auch alles gar nicht aus. Ja, Motorola und UNIX, so haben wir uns ja dann auch kennengelernt irgendwann. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, wann das war. Auf jeden Fall warst du der Typ, der diesen Computer hatte.
Ach, nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich. Ich war vielleicht...
Du warst auf jeden Fall derjenige, der uns Zugang gegeben hat zu dieser ominösen Maschine damals. Wir reden jetzt von, wovon reden wir? Mitte der 80er Jahre und Hannover. Und da hast du in einer Firma gearbeitet, und das war wahrscheinlich die einzige Firma in Deutschland, die wusste, wie man UNIX schreibt.
Och nee, es gab schon eine Menge andere Firmen auch. Es gab der Stollmann, an der Zeit, wenn man sich noch entsinnt, die ja damals auch UNIX-Ports gemacht hat in Hamburg.
Tatsächlich.
Für verschiedenste Zecke, Messtechnik glaube ich viel.
Klar, alle haben irgendwie ein bisschen... Hier und da gab es mal UNIX, aber an sich war das einfach auch in der Computerlandschaft ein unbekanntes Feld.
Ist ein Exot gewesen, keine Frage.
Niemand hat da so auch mit gerechnet, dass das irgendwann nochmal so kommt.
Genau. Und wir hatten damals so einige oder andere Projekte im Kommunikationsbereich bei der Firma, wo ich da angestellt war. Und es ergab sich so, dass wir ja eines Tages eine Maschine mit dem ominösen Namen Focus 6.3, es war nämlich so eine Motorola 6300, 8.8.000 Maschine mit diesem Conversion-Mini-Frame UNIX drauf, übrig hatten mit einem Kommunikationsanschluss und die habe ich dann second fremdet und habe sie als Maschine mit offenem Shell-Zugang, also Gast kam direkt rein ohne Kennwort auf eine Shell, mit UCP-Zugang, mit Mail-Möglichkeiten direkt ins Internet und auch News-Zugang damals zur Verfügung gestellt hat, dass man sich jeder Hanoveraner einloggen konnte oder jeder, der nach Hanover telefonieren wollte, wie es damals hieß.
Und der ein Modem hatte und überhaupt einen Computer hatte und wusste, was er da überhaupt tut. Ich war so einer dieser begünstigten und ich weiß noch, wie ich viel Zeit verbracht habe auf dieser Maschine, ohne dass ich so richtig eigentlich wusste, wo ich bin. Man hat ja damals Mailboxen benutzt. Also es gab halt so diese ersten Mailbox-Systeme, da loggt man sich ein und dann sagt man dann Hallo, willkommen auf unserer Box. Du hast irgendwie fünf Nachrichten. Tralala, hier schreibt auch mal ein schwarzes Brett und so. Das war dann halt alles irgendwie sehr, wie soll ich sagen, da gab es halt so eine Art Benutzerführung. Das war natürlich auch alles immer sehr arkan, aber man wusste eigentlich schon, worum es ging. Und dann rief man halt dieses UNIX an und es sagte Dollar.
Login Doppelpunkt.
Ja, es sagte Login Dollar und dann hat man sich halt eingeloggt, aber dann sagte es halt Dollar. Und das war eigentlich alles, was es zu einem sagte. Und dann weiß ich halt noch, das war für mich wirklich auch so der erhebende Internet-Moment, von dem ich noch gar nicht wusste, dass das werden würde. Ich habe halt einfach dann rumgestorrt. Und wie man das so macht, man halt immer alle Programme, die sich irgendwie angeboten haben, einfach mal ausprobiert oder eigentlich alle zwei buchstabigen Abkürzungen ausprobiert, die ich gerade so einfinde. Und irgendwann bleibe ich halt bei dem Kommando RN hängen. Der Eingeweihte weiß schon, Read News, das ist so einer der damals verbreiteten Clients gewesen unter UNIX, mit dem man halt News gelesen hat, wobei News bezieht sich halt hier auf Newsnet News, so quasi der Vorläufer aller schwarzen Brettsysteme. Und ja, und dann blätterte ich einfach so durch so Nachrichten durch. Und irgendwelche Leute redeten über irgendwas. Und ich blätterte mir das stundenlang durch. Und ich hatte keine Ahnung, was ich da gefunden habe. Ich dachte erst, ich bin jetzt in irgendeinem Archiv oder so. Also als würde ich in so einem Buch blättern. Das war so ein bisschen mein Gefühl. Und erst nach einer Weile wurde mir irgendwie klar, diese Leute, erstens, die reden alle miteinander, zweitens, dann habe ich mir das Statum angeschaut, das ist alles bestenfalls ein paar Wochen her, dass sie das geschrieben haben, weil da sind so Absendendatum dran und die sitzen alle in den USA. Wie kommen die jetzt auf meinen Computer? Das war für mich irgendwie vollkommen unklar. Und da wurde mir so langsam klar, oh mein Gott, ich bin an die Welt angeschlossen. Es gibt andere Lebewesen, es gibt ein intelligentes Leben außerhalb meiner Stadt. Das war echt erstaunlich. Ich glaube, diese Maschine hat das bei einer Menge Leute mit eingebracht, weil es war ja, es gab, man muss sich das vorstellen, Internet, das Wort gab es nicht, oder?
Damals war es nicht so verbreitet.
Nein, eigentlich gab es das Apernet, aber auch das war einem eigentlich alles nicht so bewusst. Man wusste, es gibt Modems und man konnte halt andere Computer anrufen, aber es war halt alles eigentlich rotierte um diese Idee des Bulletin Board Systems der Computer-Mailbox. Und dann war halt einfach dieser Computer da, der eigentlich auch erstmal so tat, als wäre er das. Und dann ist da auf einmal die Welt zu Gast. Das war schon echt unfassbar. Und du hast ja auch so was Ähnliches dann auch so ein Kommunikationssystem programmiert für eine nicht ganz unbekannte Organisation.
Ja, das war damals dann ein Auftrag gewesen, der von der Firma Heise, die ja heutzutage in der Branche jeder kennt, als Verleger.
Den News Provider schlechthin.
Genau, die wollten damals eins dieser schwarzen Bredssysteme, nämlich wirklich herkömmliche Benutzerüberfläche mit einem schwarzen Bredssystem obendrauf, für sich selber haben, für die Kommunikation im Heiseumfeld, für ihre Zeitungen, für ihre Listings, die es ja damals schon gab, diese CT-Listings, die vertrieben wurden. Die sollte eben halt programmiert werden und in Form von damaligen x25 Netzen ins Netz gestellt werden, Modemnetze und x25 Netzwerke. Und sollte halt dann auch Gateway spielen zu verschiedenen Annetzen, insbesondere auch zum Netnew-System sollte Gateway sein und dergleichen. Das Ganze war dann das Cosmonet-Projekt.
Und das orientierte sich so ein bisschen an CompuServe, oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen. In der Idee her. Der eine von den Projektmanagern von der Heise-Seite war auch ein starker CompuServe-User gewesen und da lässt sich der Einfluss nicht ganz...
Ja, CompuServe war ja damals eigentlich das einzig nennenswerte, wirklich länderübergreifende Netz, wenn man so will. Also richtig stark war es nur in den USA, aber es war halt zumindest theoretisch möglich, das auch in Europa zu benutzen, auch wenn das natürlich scheiße teuer war. Aber daraus ist nie so richtig was geworden, oder?
Nee, das ist glaube ich direkt überholt worden vom Internet. Das ist direkt schon von vornherein irgendwie auf der rechten Spur designt gewesen. Das Internet war schon schwer im Anmarsch gewesen, aber hat sich in Europa noch nicht so angesehen. Da war ja noch alles so mit OSI-Protokollen X25 vernetzt. Auch das DFN hat sich ja schwer getan, das Internet zu begreifen in der Anfangsphase. Und so auch damals wurde dann auch dann gemerkt, ach nein, das müssen wir alles ganz anders machen. Und heutzutage sieht man ja, wie es gemacht worden ist. Heute macht man es mit dem Internet, mit Web-Servern und dergleichen. Haben die aber früher erkannt und haben das Projekt gar nicht erst nach einer langen, großenartigen Laufzeit auch gleich beerdigt wieder.
Heise ist wirklich eine der wenigen Organisationen, die wirklich Technologie auch begreifen, oder?
Ja, denke ich mir. Die haben es auf jeden Fall auch ausprobiert. Die wollten auch probieren, was können wir machen, was können wir erreichen, wie erreichen wir unsere Kunden. Und ich habe da eben halt mal mitgespielt, für eine Weile in einem Projekt.
Der Heise-Verlag hat ja auch damals in dieser Hanoveraner Computerszene, die sich durch diese Cebit auch immer so ein bisschen an Hanoveraner Computerszene war einfach dadurch immer schon ein bisschen anders als in den anderen Städten, weil einfach die Cebit so viel Magnetismus entwickelt hat. Viele Leute haben sich deswegen dann auch für Computer interessiert und durch die ganzen Zeitungsprojekte, die da auch abgingen, das war ja dann schon auch so ein Katalysator, hat sich mal eine Menge getan. Aber das war dann letzten Endes, um mal ein bisschen vorzuspulen, alles dann irgendwann nicht mehr dein Ding. Und dann hast du dann irgendwie eine andere Firma gegründet, namens Helios Software, und dort habt ihr angefangen, ja, mit Fileservern zu arbeiten.
Ja, Fileserver und dann im Weiterführen dann auch Software für Prepress, für Macs, aber im Wesentlichen erstmal Fileserving, was jetzt in unserem Kontext wichtig ist.
Und das Hura-Produkt war da das ESA-Share, was so ein kommerzieller, ja, eine kommerzielle UNIX-basierte Alternative war zu dem, ja, was gab's denn damals eigentlich von Apple? Es gab Apple-Share, da konnte man sich so einen normalen Macintosh kaufen, und dann hatte man dort einen Fileserver-Dienst, und dazu habt ihr sozusagen ein Replacement gemacht.
Der war exklusiv dafür zuständig, der hat dann nichts anderes mehr gemacht. Das war sozusagen der dedizierte Server, wie man so früh auch die Novell-Server kannte. Die waren dann irgendwo zentral. Da lief ein Spezialdienst drauf, und da war kein anderes normales Programm mehr drauf laufähig. Also auch, obwohl es ein Mac war, sobald dann der Apple-Share-Dienst drauf lief, dann war der blockierte Rechner, da lief nichts anderes mehr. Und er hatte auch so seine Probleme. Er war halt auf der Macintosh-Hardware, die damals ja noch relativ schmalbrüstig war, und konnte nicht so sehr viele Clients verwalten, hatte dann also auch gar keinen richtigen Druckdienst, in dem Sinne, dass man also nicht damit überdrucken konnte, dass man also keine Spooler-Funktionalität hatte. Und ich habe damals gesagt, wir haben doch jetzt diese schönen UNIX-Maschinen hier, und die können doch eigentlich so im Hintergrund eine ganze Menge Dienste miterledigen. Die sind nicht dediziert, da kann man das ja mit so einem Programm, was hinten dann D heißt, einem Dämon, auch im Hintergrund erledigen, und dann kann man da zum Beispiel das Fallsystem zur Verfügung stellen von denen. Die hatten ja auch schon größere Platten angeschlossen als die etwas schmickrigen, von Apple erhältlichen Platten damals. Und hatten vielleicht auch die Möglichkeit, die Druckjobs zwischendurch zu speichern. Und das war dann die Idee, einfach eine UNIX-Maschine als Zentralen Server zu verwenden, multifunktional. Für alle möglichen anderen Sachen auch noch.
Warum habt ihr dann ausgerechnet zum Mac sozusagen gegriffen als Markt?
Schon in meinem Job vorher habe ich mich schon intensiv mit Mac beschäftigt. Ich habe damals schon mit den allerersten Macs, die rauskamen, und den allerersten Laser-Wreiter, die rauskamen, mich mit dem Mac beschäftigt. Programmiereumgebung damals. Die Firma, wo ich da beschäftigt war, die hat dann auch Mac-Programmiereumgebungen verkauft. So C und Pascal und Assembler-Entwicklungsumgebung. Wir haben Programme dafür gemacht und haben Pascal-Dokumentationen dafür gemacht und Support für die Kunden von den Entwicklungssystemen. Und haben dann sehr viel mit der Programmierung auf dem Mac beschäftigt. Und das Ding hat mir eigentlich von vornherein, als es rauskam, von 1984 weg hin, gut gefallen. Und deswegen war der Mac im Moment dabei.
Obwohl die Programmierer ja eigentlich immer ein bisschen geklagt haben über das aufwändige Programmieren?
Es ist aufwändig, aber das Ergebnis ist einfach wirklich hübsch und wirklich gut benutzbar und hat mir immer gut gefallen. Deswegen war auch in der Neugründung der Firma, die wir so Ende 1988 gegründet haben, und 1989 dann wirklich als GmbH-Gründung mit eigenem Büro da stand, der erste Bürorechner war ein Macintosh. Da lief alles drauf, was Briefe schreiben, Rechnung schreiben und sonst irgendwie drauf lief. Der hatte einen Laserdrucker angeschlossen. Und da hatten wir zwar auch UNIX-Arbeitsstationen, die für Entwicklung gedacht waren, aber für Business haben wir gedacht, die ganzen Schreibkramen und so, das bleibt bei Mac, das wird nicht anders gemacht. Und da war auch schon gleich bei uns das selbe Problem. Wir hatten als kleine gründete Firma nur einen Drucker in der Firma, einen Laserdrucker. Jetzt mussten wir dieses Teufelsding auch irgendwie an die UNIX-Maschinen reinkriegen. Und dann fing das dann schon auch an mit den ersten Beschäftigen, was reden denn da diese Macintoshes überhaupt für ein komisches Protokoll? Das ist was ganz anderes. Sie reden zwar auf dem Ethernet auch irgendwas, ein Protokoll, aber das ist nicht TC-Pipe, das ist was anderes.
Genau, der Mac hat Apple Talk zum Einsatz gebracht.
Ja, als Protokoll.
Als Protokoll, genau.
Auf den verschiedenen Medien.
Auf Ethernet und auch auf dem Local Talk, schön billig zu vernetzen auf jeden Fall, von Rechner zu Rechner gespannt, was ja damals eigentlich auch Standard war. Ich meine, Ethernet, das waren alles noch diese Koaxialkabel und so, von den Switches, die man heute kennt, wenn man noch weit entfernt. Und was habt ihr dann gemacht? Also ihr habt euch das Protokoll angeschaltet, also ihr habt es sozusagen selber das Bedürfnis, ihr müsst jetzt mal irgendwie auf eure eigenen Dateien zugreifen, aber das war ja schon eigentlich von Anfang an das Ziel oder so.
Das war nicht von Anfang an das Ziel. Darauf gekommen sind wir eigentlich durch Kommunikation mit benachbarten Apple-Händlern, die direkt um die Ecke waren. Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch erinnerst, wo in Hannover war das gewesen, weil da gab damals von einer Hamburger Firma... Ich hab's jetzt auch vergessen. Ich weiß, da gab's da eine Filiale und die hatten Macintosh-Verkauf und die hatten dann schon häufigerweise im Verlagswesen angefangen Macintosh-Verkauf und hatten dann gesagt, da und da gibt es die Probleme, ihr seid ein Programmierer, guckt euch das doch mal an. Und die haben uns sozusagen auch ein bisschen drauf gestoßen, da gibt es Probleme zu lösen. Und deswegen kam dann auch die Idee, wir kennen UNIX, wir kennen den Mac ganz gut, lass uns doch mal versuchen, die UNIX-Maschinen als zentrale Server für Macintoshes zu benutzen. Und so ist dann die Entwicklung gestartet.
Ja, können wir jetzt den Überblick auch mal abschließen. Also, ISA-Share ist ja dann ein ziemlicher Erfolg geworden. Das hat sich da im UNIX-Bereich eigentlich weit verbreitet, universitären Spektrum und sonst irgendwie. Aber jetzt würde ich halt ganz gerne mal so auf die Technik kommen, darum soll es ja hier eigentlich primär gehen. Vielleicht fangen wir einfach mal mit AFP jetzt an und lassen dabei glaube ich mal das Apple Talk, kann man glaube ich eigentlich rauslassen? Oder gibt es da irgendwie, kann man nicht rauslassen?
Nee, und zwar, wenn man die Geschichte ein bisschen auf einen geht. Wenn du jetzt mehrere Protokolle, File-Protokolle vergleichst, die drei buchstabigen Sachen, so NFS, Network-Faltestim von Zann, auf die IP-Basis für UNIX-Workstations designt, Apple Talk von Apple auf dem Local Talk Klingeldraht Medium designt für die Kommunikation von Macintoshes, oder SMB von IBM designt, um MS-DOS-Maschinen mit dem original MS-DOS-Betriebssystem zu einem zentralen Zwei-Faltserver reden zu lassen. Da sind verschiedene Kriterien hinter Design-Kristallien. Zum Beispiel das Local Talk Medium war langsam, 300 Kbit pro Sekunde oder so etwas. Das war also nicht besonders schnell. Und da drehte sich alles um eine möglichst effiziente Darstellung der Pakete. Da durfte kein Byte verschwendet werden, da würde nichts verschwendet. Die Pakete waren alle ganz klein angepasst. Die Kommunikation war auch zum Teil so eingerichtet, dass sie in den Protokollen übereinstimmten mit dem unterliegenden Medium. Also das Protokoll Apple Talk obendrauf, was auf dem Local Talk abgebildet wurde, hatte auch Zusammenhänge damit. Das lief zusammen.
Hat Rücksicht genommen.
Rücksicht genommen, genau. Mit der Steuerung von der Zuweisung von Knotennummern und so weiter. Mit dem Namensprotokoll und so weiter. Das war vorne rein in den Protokoll eingebaut. Und das AFP, wenn man sich das anguckt heutzutage, dann sieht das immer so aus, als hätte jemand versucht, alles in eine Streichholzschachtel zu packen. Also alle Daten sind da ziemlich komprimiert drinnen. Man sieht also überall, dass es tierisch gepackt ist. Das kommt alles aus der Historie heraus. Das siehst du bei NFS nicht. Bei NFS hat man immer große Integers reingepackt und Padding und muss alles schon gerade sein. Network Byte Order haben sie beim AFP-Protokoll auch mal verwendet, weil die waren ja mit 38.000 Computern versehen. Da ergab sich der Network Byte Order schon, glaube ich, automatisch oder fast zufällig.
Sollte man vielleicht mal kurz erklären, also die Network Byte Order Prozessoren, also Intel Prozessoren und Motorola Prozessoren, vor allem die beiden größten verbreiteten, haben halt einfach ihre Bytes andersrum gespeichert. Wenn man so einen 32-Bit-Wert hat, dann ging es von dem einen von links nach rechts und von dem anderen von rechts nach links. Da muss man immer ein bisschen nachdenken, bei welchem es jetzt VIRUM war. Auf jeden Fall war es anders. Und man hat sich dann halt darauf geeinigt, dass so wie der Motorola das macht, dass das eben die Network Byte Order ist.
Oder Big Endian.
Big Endian, was Insta, ich meine, würde es mir wahrscheinlich zustimmen, sodass es so eigentlich gemeinhin wird, so angesehen, dass Intel es eigentlich falsch rummacht und die anderen machen es eigentlich richtig rum. Aber da kann man dann lange drüber streiten, auf jeden Fall ist Big Endian sehr religiös. Big Endian hat sich allein dadurch durchgesetzt, weil Sun Microsystems schlicht und ergreifend einfach Networking an der Stelle dann auch definiert hat mit ihren Maschinen. Ich glaube, das war IBM.
IBM hat auch schon Big Endian verwendet. Und war da, glaube ich, noch bestimmender.
Mit den Mainframes malst du jetzt noch.
Ja, und zwar die Bits in den Worten andersrum durchnummeriert, anders als alle anderen. Es gibt also nicht nur den Byte Order innerhalb des Speichers.
Es gibt auch noch die Bit Order innerhalb des Bytes.
Natürlich. Von woher zählst du? Was ist Bit Null? Bei IBM das Höchstwertigste und bei allen anderen das Niederwertigste. Also da gibt es Unterschiede, da kreuzen sich die Fußnägel durch die Schuhe nach oben.
Aber das heißt, dass IBM schon die richtige Reihenfolge der Bytes, aber nicht die richtige Reihenfolge der Bits hatte?
Doch, die richtige weitere Bit-Reihenfolge war auch, nur die Nummerierung war anders. Das ist nur für den Schwierigsten, der die Dokumentation liest.
Ach so, das Bit Sieben war sozusagen das, was zwischen 0 und 1 und Bit 6 war, was 2 und 4.
Das ist also gruselig.
Also wir halten fest, es gibt diese Network-Bite-Order und die wurde dann auch von Apple gemacht, weil die halt Motorola-Prozessoren hatten, da hatten sie das halt auch automatisch. Also Local Talk macht übrigens, habe ich gerade mal nachgeschaut, 232 Kilowatt pro Sekunde. Das war sogar noch ein bisschen langsamer.
Ja, das ist dann die Erinnerung.
Das kann man sich schon heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen, dass man das mal so langsam gemacht hat. Aber es ging eigentlich ganz gut.
Das war eine kostengünstige Lösung. Man konnte mit einem einfachen Serien-Ship das machen.
Genau. Das war auch so für damalige gefühlte... Ich meine, damals waren die Dateien ja auch nicht so groß.
Genau.
Ging das eigentlich alles relativ fix.
War erträglich.
Genau, es war erträglich. Es war jetzt nicht Highspeed, aber man wollte halt an diesen Text ran und den hat man dann auch schnell gekriegt. So, du sagst, Apple Talk mit seiner Berücksichtigung von langsamen Interfaces, das hat auch sehr abgefärbt auf den eigentlichen Dienst, über den wir jetzt reden, der auch häufig von Leuten Apple Talk genannt wird, was natürlich nicht richtig ist. Eigentlich ist es Apple Share und auch das ist nicht richtig, weil das ist ja eigentlich nur das Produkt von Apple, was AFP, das eigentliche Protokoll, implementiert hat. Aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass Leute das Protokoll wirklich AFP genannt haben, bis vor ein paar Jahren vielleicht.
Das war glaube ich nicht so üblich.
Überhaupt nicht. Also man redete immer von Apple Share und jeder war total durcheinander und sagte mal Apple Talk und mal dies. Aber Apple Share, sprich AFP, das ist der eigentliche Dienst, der eben darauf aufsetzt und irgendwann sind sie damit aber auch dann auf TCPIP gegangen.
Da wurde dann mal gewechselt, als dann gesehen wurde, dass dann Internet das dominante Medium geworden ist und dann eigentlich Macs auch nicht mehr ausgestattet wurden mit den alten Local Talk Schnittstellen, als die seriellen Schnittstellen mal wegfielen. Dann wurde gesehen, das geht gar nicht mehr. Man muss dann also mal langsam auf TCPIP überwechseln.
Weil da kommt das Internet und da wird er nicht dran vorbeikommen. Zumal ja auch Apple Talk wirklich, korrigiere mich, aber vom Design her für sehr überschaubare Netzwerkgrößen gemacht war und für so einen Wide-Area-Betrieb nicht wirklich taugte.
Nein, also das Routing und die ganzen Mechanismen, wie Routing-Tabellen weitertransportieren, sind nicht unbedingt wirklich skalierend. Das ist für kleine Netze gedacht. Alle großen Netze, Apple Talk-Netze mit vielen Rautern dazwischen, tendieren zu komischen Effekten. Schwingungen, Schwebungen, wie Welleneffekte auf den Routing-Tabellen.
Das ist ziemlich komplex. Aber für kleine Netze muss ich sagen, hat es damals schon besser funktioniert als TCPIP heute. Also es war immer alles selbst konfigurieren.
Plug & Play von vorne rein, vom Design her.
Drucker einschalten, man sieht ihn. Da kann man ja heute beten, dass es wirklich so ist. Aber wir wollen jetzt hier nicht über Apple Talk schwärmen, sondern einfach mal gucken, was macht denn AFP?
Im Wesentlichen ist AFP das Protokoll, was von der Programmierung her alle Zugriffe auf Dateien von einem Rechner transportiert auf einen anderen Rechner. Also, ziemlich an der Programmierschnittstelle, ich will eine Datei öffnen, ich will eine Datei lesen, ich will Attribute über eine Datei wissen, werden abgefangen, ziemlich an der obersten Ebene, direkt im System Kern, wo der Programmierer sie gegeben hat in seiner Applikation, wird entschieden, das File ist nicht lokal auf meiner eigenen Festplatte, nein, das ist entfernt, also muss ich den Call ziemlich eins zu eins rübergeben zu dem Server, der diese Datei wirklich lokal zur Führung stellt und der wird mir dann die Sache beantworten, was ich jetzt gerade wissen will. Ich will mal wegen 500 bytes lesen irgendwo in der Datei oder ich will von der Datei wissen, wie groß ist sie oder wie alt ist sie und dergleichen. Der wesentliche Punkt ist, es wird immer versucht, nahe an der Applikation, also an der System-Call-Schnittstelle, die ganzen File-Aktivitäten abzufangen und auf einem anderen Rechner zu übertragen. Egal, welches Protokoll es ist, ob es ein AFP, NFS oder ZIFS oder SMB ist. Und deshalb sieht man auf diesen Protokollen auch sehr deutlich, welche Betriebssystems-Schnittstelle implementiert worden ist. Wenn du dir den NFS anguckst, dann siehst du das klare, deutliche, simple, einfache, Open, Read, Write, Close, UNIX-Io-Konzept. Guckst du dir AFP an, da siehst du nahezu barocke Zugriffsmöglichkeiten, wie Macintosh sie immer geboten haben, auf alternative Resource-Forks, Zugriff auf Dateien via einer ID, Unique ID. Es musste ja funktionieren, dass man als Benutzer eine Datei beliebig im File-System verschieben kann und die Applikation muss immer noch darauf zugreifen können. Das funktionierte dann auch im Netz? Das funktionierte auch im Netz, es funktionierte mit Hilfe von Unique IDs.
Eine der großartigsten Funktionalitäten von Apple Netzen überhaupt. Man schiebt einfach die Datei auf dem File-Server durch die Gegend und ein Alias, der lokal ist, findet die dann einfach.
Ja, findet sogar den Server.
Findet sogar den Server, genau. Man macht einfach so einen Doppel-Click, macht den Server auf und findet die Datei, auch wenn sie verschoben ist, schon echt top.
Sehr gute Idee, aber es war eben auch eine ganze Menge Aufwand da drin. Allerdings. Aber in den Protokollen sieht man dann also, wo sie herkommen. Welche System-Schnittstelle darauf abgebildet wurde.
Du sagst Barocke, Barocke ist Interface. Was war denn da so Barock daran? Weil es so viele Einstiegspunkte hatte?
Barock deswegen, weil es, vielleicht bin ich da an der Stelle, auch die UNIX-Sichtweise. Also ich habe sehr viel unter UNIX programmiert und ich habe da die sehr einfache und simple UNIX-System-Colt-Schnittstelle im Hinterkopf. Das bedeutet, ich kann die Datei öffnen, ich kann davon lesen, ich kann darauf schreiben. Also dieses Open, Read, Write, Close, L-Seek und das war es so ziemlich. Oder Stadt vielleicht auch noch. Und diese Brille hat eine sehr einfache Brille auf das Dateisystem. Jeder Datei hat einen Namen, es ist ein Weitstream von Daten drin und das war es so ziemlich. Bei Mac kommt dann noch solche exotischen Sachen dazu, wie es gibt nicht nur eine Datenfrog, sondern zwei oder in späteren Versionen des AFP-Colt auch beliebig viele Frogs. Eine Datenfrog, eine Resourcefrog. Die Resourcefrog ist ja historisch in Mac gesehen eine strukturierte, weitere Datei gewesen, die an jeder Datei dran sein kann, wo dann die sogenannten Ressourcen drin waren. Eine Art kleine Miniatur, strukturierte Datenbank, wo dann die ganzen Informationen für Lokalisierung bei Programmen drin waren. Und zusätzliche Attribute, wie zum Beispiel ein Kommentar, dass man zum Beispiel als Benutzer einfach einen Kommentar pro Datei ablegen kann, bis 199 Zeichen in der Länge, wo man einfach was reinschreiben konnte mit der Datei.
Ohne, dass man die Datei halt selber ändert.
Genau, oder dass man im Betriebssthema, dem Icon, was dafür dargestellt wurde, eine Farbe geben kann. Jeder Datei hat eine Farbe, ein Label und solche Sachen. Dass diese ganzen Zusatzattribute, die sich im User-Interface wieder schieben, spiegeln sich dann über dem File-Protokoll auf dem Kabel, dann in dem Protokoll auch wieder, dass es da solche Sachen gibt, die man abrufen kann, die man bei anderen Betriebssthema erst mal nicht kennt. Und deswegen sind sie das Barock, weil das User-Interface-Design, das Macintosh da, sich durchschlägt.
Klar.
Und bei anderen Protokollen, wie zum Beispiel NFS, das ist relativ simpel und einfach gehalten, auf dieser auch relativ simpel und einfachen Schnittstelle und ist sehr klar strukturiert. Und zum Beispiel, im Gegensatz zu ZIFS oder SMB, auch gut dokumentiert. Also beide, Apple Talk, AFP, TCPIP, NFS, sind ja voll durchdokumentierte Protokolle, von oben bis unten, sind alle dokumentiert, jeder kann das implementieren. Apple war da von vornherein auch so. Damals die Designer von Apple Talk und AFP haben in ihrem damals für uns die Bibel Buch Inside Apple Talk von Guro Hamzitu und Alen Oppenheimer alles von oben bis unten komplett dokumentiert.
Schon immer?
Schon immer. Das war von unten, das Local Talk Kabel, Ethernet und auf Tokenringen, wie das abgebildet wird. Das war alles in dem Buch drinnen. Das Filing-Protokoll, das Printing-Protokoll, alle Protokolle, das Name-Binding, waren von oben bis unten auf das Bit dokumentiert. Natürlich mit der Macintosh-Brille aufgesetzt. Wenn man da reinguckt und nicht weiß, wie innerhalb des Mac-Betriebs-Stims Files dargestellt werden, sind da einige Sachen unverständlich, aber vom Prinzip her eigentlich komplett dokumentiert.
Trotzdem gab es eigentlich relativ wenig Third-Party-Implementierungen von AFP, oder? Lange Zeit?
Ja, es war wenig, weil es war auch relativ kompliziert darzustellen. Also ich hab mir da zum Teil manchmal wirklich einen abgebrochen, um das darzustellen, weil ein Macintosh doch zum Teil sehr anders ist. Und bei der Emulation, der Semantik des Mac-Betriebssystems auf normalen Flat-File-Pass-Based-Betriebssystem, wo einfach Pfadnamen dargestellt werden, extrem schwierig ist. Da gibt es viele Fußangeln.
Wie zum Beispiel diese ID, die wir schon erwähnt haben?
Ja, Zugriff de facto eigentlich nur über IDs. Das Mac-Betriebssystem greift selber nicht über Pfadnamen zu, sondern immer nur über IDs. Es gibt immer ein Parent-ID, das ist die Nummer eines Ordners, wo eine Datei drin ist und den Namen, wo man dann weiter traversieren kann. Ein Pfad ergibt sich immer durch Nummern im Mac-Betriebssystem und nicht durch einen Pfadnamen-Düntags. Das Wichtige ist auch diese mehrfachen Forks, die es gibt. Früher zwei, jetzt mehr, beliebige. Als einfacher UNIX-Programmierer legt man sich an die Karten. Wenn man also anfängt mit dem Umbenennen einer Datei, zum Beispiel von mehreren Prozessen aus, wenn man z.B. mehrere Clients dran hat, was verschiebe ich zuerst? Ressorts-Frog, die Daten-Frog, was sieht er zuerst? Wo gibt es Konflikte? Ist ja nicht atomisch. Ich mache das ja als Applikation. Wenn ich das atomische UNIX-Kernel mit einem Renamen-Call umbenennen könnte, dann wäre das ja vielleicht ganz einfach. Aber der kennt ja keine mehreren Forks, also kann ich auch nicht das in einem Call machen.
Das mit diesen Forks, das ist ja so eine ganz besondere Eigenart des Macs immer schon gewesen. Tatsächlich ist ja Apple auf der einen Seite mit Mac OS X so ein bisschen davon abgekommen, weil sie auch letztlich auf UNIX umgestellt haben. Natürlich gibt es die Forks noch, aber sie spielen halt nicht mehr die alte Rolle. Du hast ja schon gesagt, Lokalisierung hat sich da zum Beispiel drin gefunden, aber es war ja auch das komplette User-Interface da drin abgelegt, die ganzen Dialoge. Man konnte da ja alles Mögliche ändern, wenn man diesen Ressource-Editor genommen hat, konnte man ja Programme komplett verunstalten, ohne halt an dem Code irgendwas zu ändern, also das eigentliche Binary wurde überhaupt nicht angetouched. Trotzdem sind sie davon irgendwie abgekommen. Mittlerweile liegt das ja auch alles ganz normal in Flat Files, also eine Macintosh-Applikation ist jetzt in so einem Bundle, was letztendlich nichts anderes ist, als ein wohlstrukturiertes Verzeichnis von Dateien. Trotzdem sagst du aber, jetzt wurde das aber noch erweitert, also es gibt sozusagen nicht nur den einen Fork, sondern es gibt auch noch mehrere.
Es gibt benutzerdefinierte Forks, man kann wie in der Macintosh-Welt üblich mit so einem 4-Byte-ID eine beliebige Fork ansprechen. Und es gibt dann halt diese zwei vordefinierten RSRC und Data. Das sind die beiden Forks, die vordefiniert sind und man kann beliebig viele Forks anlegen. Wofür wird das benutzt?
Benutzt das überhaupt irgendjemand oder gibt es das einfach nur?
Es gibt ganz wenig Applikationen, die sowas verwenden. Aber Ressorts und Data gibt es dann schon häufig, auch heute immer noch.
Im Prinzip ist das ja schon eine Vorwegnahme des heutigen Trends zu Metadaten, auch im Datalsystem. Auch andere Datalsysteme haben ja Metadaten mittlerweile auch angenommen, sowohl unter BSD als auch unter Linux. Man will eben genau das, was du vorhin schon gesagt hast. Man will halt mal einen Kommentar absetzen. Man will das irgendeiner Kategorie zuordnen.
MIME-Type setzen oder dergleichen.
Genau, MIME-Type setzen und so weiter. So mehr Suchbegriffe.
Indizierung, Staatsablegen für Indizierung und so weiter.
Genau, genau. Oder irgendwelche eigenen Dinge wie müsste ich mal ein Backup von machen oder soll nie gebackupt werden. Also einfach Metadaten. Sind diese Extended Attributes in anderen Datalsystemen dann auch über solche Fork-Geschichten abbildbar?
Ja, die Fork-Geschichte ist ja die Generalisierung dessen. Extended Attributes, wenn du zum Beispiel SGI, Extended File System, XFS anguckst, die hatten dann bis zu 64K Extended Attribute, die man speichern konnte. Oder manche anderen File System limitieren einfach die Extended Attribute auf so kleine Chunks, die man mit zusätzlich andet herantun. Die App-Leute haben sich einfach gesagt, wir machen einfach beliebig viele Forks. Und jedes Attribut ist eine eigene Fork. Und damit habe ich die Sache erledigt. Alle können beliebig groß sein, alle können so groß sein wie die ganze Datei. Das ist eine Generalisierung der ganzen Geschichte.
Jedes Attribut ist selber ein eigener Fork.
Ich kann zum Beispiel, wenn ich will, jeder Datei zum Beispiel einen VoiceOver unterlegen oder dergleichen, wenn ich das lustig finde. Wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Applikation habe, die immer VoiceOvers unter einer ResourceFork Voice ablegt, dann kann ich für jede Datei einen VoiceOver ablegen.
Sodass dann der Computer immer irgendwas sagt, wenn man sich die Datei anschaut.
Genau, sowas kann man sich zum Beispiel vorstellen. Es gibt bestimmt noch bessere Ideen als ich. Ich bin da vielleicht gar nicht so gut in der kreativen Nauseus bei. Aber es gibt beliebige Möglichkeiten. Die Extended Attributes sind nicht limitiert in der Länge, sondern jeder Extended Attribute kann so lang sein wie die ganze Datei.
Also AFP ist dann auch ein Dateisystem, ein Fileserver-Protokoll, was solche Sachen theoretisch unterstützen könnte. Praktisch wird es aber eigentlich kaum genutzt.
Wird selten genutzt heutzutage noch. Nur die Metadaten, die schon im Betriebssystem drin sind, die werden die Ressource-Frogs, die erweiterten Finder-Metadaten, und dann hat sich das eigentlich schon...
Wenn man jetzt mal auf die anderen beiden Fileserver-Protokolle schaut, die du schon erwähnt hast, also NFS und SMB, ich denke, das sind so die erwähnenswertesten in dem Zusammenhang. Oder gibt es noch andere Fileserver-Protokolle, die eigentlich so maßgeblich waren für die Entwicklung im Allgemeinen?
Auf was viele gesehen haben, vielleicht ein Novell-Protokolle oder Bunion-Vines oder dergleichen, die immer in der frühen DOS-Welt üblich waren, die aber heute eigentlich fast nur irgendwo verwendet werden. Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass wenn Filesharing gemeint wird, dann wird Filesharing gemeint mit NFS, SMB oder AFP fast überall.
Das sind die drei, die überlebt haben?
Ja, wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwelche Internet-Protokolle wie vielleicht noch WebDAV damit reinrated, die dann in eine ähnliche Richtung gehen.
Es gab auch mal so ein Andrew-Filesystem, AFS?
Das gibt es immer noch. Das ist eine sehr spezielle Art des Filesystems. Das ist ein Konkurrent aus der UNIX-Welt zu NFS von der Carnegie Mellon University, wo andere Design-Kriterien reinspielten und zwar das war ganz speziell als Design-Kriterien lokales Caching in einem Environment mit mehrfachen Servern, das auch sogenannte Leases gegeben wurden für ganze Dateien, dass also eine kleine ganze Dateien lokal speichern konnte und darauf lokal arbeiten konnte und erst wenn der Lease aufgegeben wird, dann wird das wieder zurück übertragen, um also eine abgesetzte Arbeitsmöglichkeit zu haben.
So eine Art Checkout einer Datei.
Ja, aber während man connected ist, ist es aber um Netzwerk-Treffik zu sparen. An Betracht der noch in universitären Netzwerken stark überlasteten Router, die zu der Zeit da waren, die also immer viel Treffik machen konnten und ein Vielfaltsystem Treffik drauf war, die in der Metze damals auch häufig zusammengebrochen. Einfach an die Überlastung der Internet an seine Grenzen gestoßen ist. Und da wollte man versuchen, Treffik zu sparen.
Hat sich aber nicht wirklich durchgesetzt, oder?
Im universitären Bereich ist es ganz häufig verwendet worden. Ich glaube, so Carnegie Mellon, so Pittsburgh, da wurde sehr viel verwendet. War aber relativ aufwendig auch zu benutzen, weil es von vornherein auf eine intensive Authentisierungsinfrastruktur zu griff. Es war nämlich nicht denkbar ohne Kerberos. AFS geht schon von vornherein gleich mit der Authentisierung mit Kerberos zu Werke.
Okay, das heißt er fordert sozusagen von vornherein auch eine höheren Anforderung an Infrastruktur.
Ja, das war eigentlich nur denkbar an dem Campus-Umfeld in der ersten Version. Vielleicht mit zwei, drei Servern, Authentifizierungs-Server, ein Time-Server, ein Ticket-Server, was sich alles dazu gehört. Das war schon relativ umfangreich.
Wer hat denn eigentlich angefangen mit diesen Fallserver-Protokollen? Wer war denn eigentlich der Erste? IBM auch wieder mit irgendwelchen Mainframe-Geschichten? Hatten die auch solche Konzepte? Oder ging das da eigentlich alles in ihren virtuellen Maschinen unter?
Nee, da gab es auch solche Fall-Protokolle. Auch schon recht früh. Aber fast unbemerkt von uns, die also mit den NQ-Computern da zur selben Zeit agierten. Da war das gar nicht sehr üblich.
Ja, war es ja auch nicht üblich, mehr als einen Computer zu haben. Was sollte man denn da auch schon groß noch vernetzen? Das heißt eigentlich losgegangen ist es wirklich erst so in den 80ern eigentlich mit dem Aufkommen von Personalkomputern oder eben auch diesen UNIX-Workstations, das man eben angefangen hat zu vernetzen. Und dann gingen sie alle mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig los, oder?
Ja, das ging also in den 80ern, Beginn der 80er Jahre. Ich würde sagen, NFS und ZAN waren da schon sehr früh mit dabei mit dem Vernetzen von UNIX-Workstations über Internetkabel. Das war schon sehr früh dabei. Und dann direkt dran waren dann auch schon die ersten IBM PC-Protokolle, die mit MS-DOS damals arbeiten, genauso gut auch die Apple-Filing-Protokolle, die waren also sehr früh mit dabei.
Jetzt hast du ja schon eben Kerberos angesprochen. Vielleicht sollten wir mal die Sicherheit ansprechen, beziehungsweise überhaupt so die Authentifizierung bei den einzelnen File-Server-Protokollen. Wie lief denn das zum Beispiel bei AFP? Also was wird denn da wirklich jetzt angefordert, damit dich auf eine bestimmte Ressource auch wirklich zugreifen kann?
Da war schon von vornherein ein Plug-In-Mechanismus vorgesehen für mehrere Authentisierungssysteme. Und das war schon von vornherein interessanterweise sicherer in den frühesten AFP-Protokollen wie die meisten anderen Protokolle auch heute noch sind. Weil dort sicher ein Mechanismus ausgedacht worden ist, der war zum Beispiel schon ganz hervorragend, zum Beispiel der Two-Way Random Number Exchange. Und zwar Authentifizierung des Benutzers und des Servers ohne Übertragung eines der Passwörter vom Benutzer oder Server irgendwie im Klartext. Es wurden also Passwörter, es wurden also Zufallszahlen ermittelt von Server und auch von Client und die wurden die über den jeweiligen bekannten Passwörter auf der lokanen Seite verschlüsselt, wird zurückgeschickt in beide Richtungen, sodass der Client wusste, ich bin mit diesem Server verbunden und der Server wusste, ich bin mit diesem Client verbunden. Und das wurde ohne Übertragung irgendwelcher Passwörter im Klartext gemacht und immerhin immer Zufallzahlen übertragen worden, die verschlüsselt worden sind. Also dieser war sehr modern, das war damals auf keinem anderen System so üblich, weil zum Beispiel NFS mit gar keiner oder ganz minimaler Sicherheit.
Mit gar keiner?
Zum großen Teil gar keine Sicherheit.
Also ich kenne das nur als Witz aus diesem großartigen UNIX-Haters Handbook. Das ziehe ich noch an dieses großartige Buch.
Ja, super.
Ich glaube, das Kapitel zur NFS ist dann mit No-File-Security übersetzt worden.
Ja, No-File-Security oder wie es dann auch manchmal heißt unter den Programmierern unter UNIX und dann Nightmare-File-System.
Nightmare-File-System. Und wie läuft denn das bei NFS?
Man gibt einer anderen Maschine per IP-Nummer meistens den Zugriff und man traut der Nutzerinfrastruktur auf der Maschine, dass sie dann dem auch entspricht, was man sich so glaubt.
Das heißt, die Autodefinition basiert ausschließlich auf Adressen, Herkunftsadressen?
Ja, im Wesentlichen. Es gibt also Varianten auch mit Kerberos und mit sogenannten Secure-RPC. Also das NFS basiert innen drin auf einer Darstellung auf ein Netzwerk, nennt sich Remote Procedural Call von Sun, RPC. Das ist von einer Konkurrenz wie DCRPC, was unten unterliegt bei Microsoft. Diese Sun-RPC gibt es in einer Ausbildung Secure-RPC, wo dann also mit Kerberos und verschlüsselt mit desverschlüsselten Sachen zum Teil verschlüsselt übertragen worden sind. Damit kann man auch eine sicherere Verbindung herstellen, inzwischen zu rechnen. Das war aber so gut wie nie üblich. Es hat mich eigentlich auch nie im echten Betrieb irgendwo gesehen. Eigentlich wenn wurden die Daten immer unverschlüsselt übertragen und es wurde davon ausgegangen, dass auf beiden Maschinen des Betriebs den selber unkompromittiert ist und sich traut gegenseitig. Das Einzige, mit dem nicht getraut wurde, war dem alten Root-User. Man hat ja mitbekommen, der Root-User wurde umgesetzt in so einen Minus-1-User auf der anderen Maschine.
Das heißt, man hat nicht automatisch, wenn man als Root kommt, auch auf der anderen Maschine Root. Aber ansonsten, das ist ja auch so eine Besonderheit. Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich No-False-Security. Das ist nicht nur so ein Witz, sondern das ist eigentlich so, man geht einfach bei NFS davon aus, dass diese Maschinen in einem sich trauenden Verbund sind. Dass da echt Böses drin ist und das muss man einfach sicherstellen. Es geht eigentlich mehr darum, den einen auf der anderen Seite genauso zu benutzen. Ich glaube, das geht sogar so weit, dass die User-ID identisch sein muss auf beiden Maschinen.
Ja, wenn man nicht irgendwelche exotischen User-ID-Mapping-Mechanismen zum Teil, die sich manche Leute ausgedacht haben, zwischenhängen möchte.
Das heißt, eigentlich macht NFS wirklich nur Sinn zwischen Maschinen, die ohnehin irgendwie auf derselben User-Database basieren.
Wenn zum Beispiel das gute alte Yellow Pages, was von Sun dann ja mal damals unbenannt werden musste, weil British Telecom als Trademark-Owner von Yellow Pages, die Sun-Leute mal eins auf den Schuh getreten hat, gesagt hat, das dürft ihr nicht Yellow Pages nennen. Dann wurde es ja unbenannt INNIS, Network Information Service.
Deswegen haben sie es unbenannt.
Ja, das war British Telecom damals, die da glaube ich mal ein bisschen aufgemuckt haben. Und da wurden dann ja auch die Benutzer- und Gruppen-Nummern, also Benutzer- und User-IDs und Gruppen-IDs und die Passwort-Informationen wurden netzgeschert dargestellt. Und dann wurde ja auch sichergestellt, dass auf allen Rechnern ein homogener User-ID und Gruppe-ID-Space war. Und dann war das ja auch kein Problem, dass man einfach nur Benutzer-Nummern und Gruppen-Nummern durch die Gegend schickt. Das wurde dann versucht in späteren Versionen des Protokolls, zum Beispiel NFS v4, was jetzt sozusagen langsam im Ansteigenbegriff ist, ausgemerzt, indem man dann wirklich Strings übermitteln kann wie User und Gruppen und ein Mapping-Mechanismus definiert worden ist, dass man das auch in homogene Rechner übereinander überführen kann.
V4 ist so die aktuelle Version?
Ja, die so gerade im Begriff ist, deploy zu werden. Der normale Linux-Benutzer wird dann so NFS v2 und v3 in seiner Maschine finden und v4 gibt es dann auch irgendwo, aber da muss man doch schon einiges von Hand noch mit How Tos flicken, bis man das in Betrieb kriegt.
Das heißt, wofür kann man ein NFS empfehlen?
Für direkt in der Nähe zusammenstehende Linux-Rechner, die unter einer Hoheit stehen. Also zum Beispiel ein Cluster von 10 Workstations, ein File-Server in der Uni oder in der Firma als Department-Rechner. Das sind die typischen Szenarios, wo man das verwenden kann. AFP, in dem Sinne hat er schon von vornherein im Protokoll schon immer User- und Gruppen-IDs mit einem Mapping-Mechanismus im Protokoll. Da war das Naming-Mechanismus mit eingebaut. Ich kann über AFP nachfragen, Server, ich habe hier einen User namens Jens-Uwe, gib mir mal die Nummer, die du dafür hast. Und kann die mappen. Das ist von vornherein im Protokoll so vorgesehen gewesen. Und das ermöglicht es auch, dass man nicht konsistente Spacer hat. Man muss also, wenn man sich anmeldet, einen Account auf dem Rechner haben, auf dem man sich anmeldet. Wenn der File-Server 12 Rechner mit einer Account-Data-Base mich hat, als Namen, kann ich ihn verwenden. Ich bekomme die Nummer und die müssen nicht dieselben sein, wie auf dem Rechner, wo ich jetzt gerade sitze. Das wird von dem AFP-Protokoll transparent gemapt.
Bei UNIX sind ja auch diese User-IDs auch eher handverlesen gewesen. Wurden dann immer so manuell hochgezählt. Das macht man wahrscheinlich bei Apple Share überhaupt nicht. Da legt man einen neuen User an und da wird irgendeine ID generiert.
Genau, es wird intern gemacht, es wird versteckt. Aber in Wirklichkeit sind da genauso viele Nummern dabei.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, dass die Authentifizierung unter anderem mit diesem Two-Way-Mechanismus schon relativ sicher funktioniert bei AFP.
Ja, schon von vornherein, schon in den frühen Versionen.
Aber die Daten selber werden natürlich nach wie vor unverschüsselt übertragen, oder?
Richtig. Das ist also bei den meisten File Sharing-Protokollen eigentlich der Standard. Es wird angenommen, dass im lokalen Netz geredet wird und die Daten werden nicht verschlüsselt übertragen. Es gibt dann also die Varianten, dass man dann z.B. mal AFP über SSL machen konnte, über die einfach SSL-Zocker-Erweiterung, denn die Variante, die über TCP geht, oder dass man auch bei SMB Varianten nehmen kann mit verschlüsselten, zu SSL verschlüsselten Sachen, aber das ist eher exoten. Es ist alles nicht dafür gedacht für Wide-Area-File Sharing. Wide-Area-File Sharing über Netzwerke, die einem unheimlich sind, sind, ja, das große, weite Internet, Wald-West, so ich das nennen möchte, wird nicht angenommen für normale File Sharing-Protokolle. Es wird immer angenommen, es ist ein administrierter Bereich innerhalb einer Firma, innerhalb eines Unicampuses, ein kleines Heim-Office bei dir, wo es alles nicht so relevant ist. Protokolle wie zum Beispiel WebDAV haben von vornherein die Möglichkeit, über HTTP oder HTTPS verschlüsselten Verkehr auszumachen, mit Authentifizierung über Zertifikate auf beiden Seiten. Das ist ja in dem Protokoll implizit vorgesehen. Sie liefern Protokolle meist nicht viel vorgesehen, weil die stammen alle aus Zeiten, wo diese Thematik eigentlich irrelevant war.
Weil Netzwerke waren einfach in einem Firmenkomplex verlegt und man konnte nicht einfach ran.
Das war eigentlich nicht üblich.
Aber bei AFP kann man zumindest auch die Verbindung mit SSL aufmachen. Das gilt dann auch in dem Moment für alle übertragene Daten. Das ist also wirklich alles verschlüsselt.
Im Endeffekt kann man das auch mit anderen Protokollen aufmachen. Das haben ja viele Leute dann durchexerziert, indem sie dann, ob es so ein SMB, NFS oder AFP ist, die über SSH tunnelt, macht einfach einen SSH-Tunnel auf und macht dann das Protokoll indirekt über einen Tunnel, der über SSH vorgewartet wird. Weil das Mac OS ja auch UNIX-basiert ist, kann man das ja auch schon ohne Probleme über Mac OS machen.
Aber heißt denn das, dass jetzt bei AFP, der Klein und der Server im Wesentlichen über eine einzige TCP-Verbindung miteinander verbunden sind und darüber läuft alles?
Ja.
Aber bei Sun ist das doch anders, oder?
Ja, bei Sun ist es, bei NFS ist es traditionell UDP gewesen. Also bei Sun hat damals gesagt, wir wollen die Ressourcen der Rechner schonen. Und das heißt nämlich Hauptmemory. Muss ich vorstellen, die damaligen UNIX-Workstations im Multi-User-Bereich hatten einen Bereich zwischen 4 und 8 MB Memory. Zu früher Sun-Workstations.
Wow, richtige Monster-Maschinen.
Richtig. Und Platz für große Bufferspaces, um viel zu puffern und große Fenster, also Fenster im Sinne von großen Windows, von Datei übertragen im TCP-Bereich, wo große Bufferspaces benötigt werden, waren eigentlich nicht über. Und man hat versucht, die File-IO-Calls direkt über UDP, über ein Paket-basierendes Protokoll eins zu eins durchzuschleusen. Das gab eben halt dann UDP-Pakete bis maximal in der Fragmentierung 8K bis 56K auf dem Original-Medium, wie also maximal ein NFS-Call so groß sein konnte.
Ok, das heißt, die waren eher auf Performance ausgelegt, um möglichst viele Klienten zu...
Und auf Memory-Schonung auch, nicht viele Buffer-Spaces im Client oder im Server zu alluzieren. Für manche Leute war es hinterher dann auch als Design-Kriterium eine bittere Pille, weil NFS funktionierte in der UDP-Variante über Router gar nicht gut. Da war kein Flow-Control drin, da war gar nichts. TCP hat ja implizit Flow-Kontrolle, dass du über Router, über Congestion, Avoidance und derartige Protokolle erkennen kannst, wenn Medien voll werden und wenn Router voll werden. UDP bietet da gar nichts und NFS selber hat da nichts implementiert. NFS ist an sich eigentlich nur für einen Netzwerkstrang an einem Internet. Wenn es über Router hinweggeht, dann war NFS schon immer schwach in der Variante über UDP, die man ursprünglich verwendet hat.
Auch das sagt wieder, eigentlich kann man NFS wirklich nur dann anwenden, wenn man wirklich eine totale große Bandbreite hat, Gigabit-Netzwerke, was weiß ich. Zumindest keine Dimentierung an der Stelle.
Heutzutage wird es auch über TCP angewendet, weil die Rechner ja auch mehr Speicher haben. Und dann wird es über eine TCP-Verbindung abgebildet, eine TCP-Verbindung. Also jeder NFS-Mount entspricht an eine TCP-Verbindung. Wogegen im AFP-Sektor jede Verbindung mit einem Server eine TCP-Verbindung ist. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Volumen von einem Mac auf einem anderen Mac mounte, dann habe ich eine AFP-Verbindung mit diesem Mac. Also jede User-Session ist eine TCP-Verbindung. Wenn ich mehrere Volumes mounte, geht die über dieselbe TCP-Connection. Wenn ich fünf Volumen habe, dann hat ein NFS für jeden Mountpoint eine TCP-Connection.
Ah ja, das heißt ja, Mac re-used sozusagen die bestehende Verbindung und kann darüber mehrere Sachen brokern. Jetzt sind wir schon auf so viele Details von NFS und AFP eingegangen, aber wir müssen ja aber auch eigentlich nochmal SMB in dem Zusammenhang erwähnen. Da müssen wir nochmal ein bisschen zurückspulen. Das klang schon an. Also SMB ist von IBM mal losgetreten worden, weil sie auch festgestellt haben, wir brauchen für unser MS-DOS auch immer so ein Fall-Sharing-System. Wenn man jetzt SMB und, ich meine, mit NFS sind sie dann wahrscheinlich beide nicht so richtig. Also AFP lässt sich mit NFS nicht so richtig vergleichen. Die haben einfach so unterschiedliche Konzepte, dann lassen wir es mal raus und vergleichen einfach SMB direkt mit AFP. Wie ähnlich sind die sich denn, wenn man jetzt mal von dem barocken Details absieht?
Nicht so fürchterlich ähnlich, weil die ersten Varianten von dem SMB-Pfilesystem waren auch eine relativ einfache Abbildung der damaligen DOS-Möglichkeiten. Da gab es nicht viel. Was SMB jetzt nun auszeichnet im Vergleich zu anderen Protokollen ist, da wird es jetzt wieder barock. Ach, da wird es auch barock. Ja, aber nicht mit barock mit der Möglichkeiten, die abgebildet werden, sondern mit den Versionen. Die Features sind barock, sondern die Vielfältigkeit. Die Vielfältigkeit der Versionen ist barock, weil im Laufe der Jahre mit dem immer leistungsfähiger werden der PC und Windows-Systeme, der DOS und Windows-Systeme, wurden dann immer mehr Features abgebildet und Stück für Stück im selben Protokoll wurden viele Calls überlagert. Die SMB kennen das in der Form von Info-Levels, dass man in ein und denselben Call Aufruf macht in eine Richtung rüber. Manchmal will ich Informationen über deine Datei wissen. Man gibt bestimmt einen Info-Level ab und je nachdem gibt es verschiedene Details in verschiedenen Versionen. In vielen Calls ist implizit noch mal eine Versionsnummer enthalten, die sagt, ich verstehe jetzt mit dem Info-Level so und so auch die und die Return-Information, die da zurückkommt. Ich bin zum Beispiel ein NT-Server, ich habe schon viel mehr Attribute. Ich bin nur ein alter OS-Halbe-Server, ich kenne die ganzen Attribute noch gar nicht untergleichen. Da gibt es also eine barocke Vielfalt von Leveln, die also dann kennzeichnen, was kann der Server in dem einzelnen Protokoll-Details an Unterschieden sehen? Kann er so große Pakete, kann er diese Authentisierung, kann er diese einzelnen Sachen... Es ist also ein großes Protokoll mit vielen verschiedenen kleinen Bereichen, die unterschiedlich sind, warum sie auseinanderstellen. Das war auch Microsoft so viel, dass sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen einen clean, sauberen Cut und haben bei Vista SMB 2.0 eingeführt. Eine komplett neue Version, die keinerlei Altlasten hat.
SMB steht für Server Message Block.
Das war wohl die original IBM-Abkürzung dafür, weil es wurden Server Message Blocks über das Netbui-Protokoll an den Server gesendet und er hat sie beantwortet. Das geht auf dieses Messaging drauf ein.
Netbui, was war denn das bitte nochmal?
Das ist die Protokolle, die man sprechen kann auf einem Verkabelungssystem. Netbui war das frühe Protokoll vor TCP-IP, womit direkten Datagramm auf dem Netzwerk ich erinnere mich, das war nicht rautbar.
Das ist das, was man, das ist diese Abkürzung, die man auch mal hinten nie richtig schreibt. Boje B-E-U-I?
Ja, ich glaube B-U-I. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Ich musste auch passen.
Okay, mal nachschlagen, was die Alvis Nimmel dazu sagt. Ja, ich hab Recht gehabt. NetBIOS Extended User Interface. Was für ein Name für ein Netzwerkprotokoll. Okay, das war sozusagen noch Pré-IP. Zurück zum SMB. Das heißt, man schickt da Blogs, wo Messages drinstehen. Macht das AFP viel anders?
Nein, auch nicht. Aber so haben sie es damals genannt. Ist dasselbe in grün. Aber mal die andere Semantik. Die Dateinamen sind dann halt DOS-style-isch. Dieses Fallsysteme sind zum Beispiel von vornherein Ketsinitiv. Das ist ja so ein großer Unterschied zwischen NFS und AFP und diesen SMB-Fallsystemen. SMB-Fallsysteme sind meistens Ketsinitiv. NFS ist generell Ketsinitiv, weil die unterliegenden Fallsysteme Ketsinitiv sind. Und AFP ist eigentlich im wesentlichen Sinne auch Ketsinitiv.
Beziehungsweise Ketspreserving muss man das glaube ich nennen, oder?
Kets ist aber heute überall so. ZB auch ZIFS ist ja so aufgestockt worden. Wobei ZIFS natürlich die Altlasten hat, ZIFS kann doch auch sowas wie alte 8.3 Namen, lange Namen und beide Namen parallel.
Da wollte ich nämlich jetzt auch gerade nochmal auf die Ketsinitiv. Bei DOS war es ja am Anfang so, es gab eigentlich nur Großbuchstaben. Das heißt, im SMB war es von Anfang an drin, ich kann zwar auch einen kleinen Buchstaben hinschreiben, aber eigentlich sind sie alle immer groß.
Ja, beim SMB-Protokoll wurde die von der Systemcolle-Schnittstelle sowieso alle in Großbuchstaben übertragen. Ich glaube, auf dem Kabel hat man nie einen kleinen Buchstaben gesehen.
Also das war case-intensitiv, weiß ich nicht, ob man das nennen kann. Also besonders sensitiv ist das ja nicht, wenn man irgendwie alles macht.
Case-sensitiv, also...
Es ist alles uppercase, sagen wir es mal so.
Genau, es wurde alles dem Schwarzen anziehen gezogen.
Und der UNIX ist traditionell alles sehr case-sensitiv, das heißt, es macht einen großen Unterschied, außer ob man einen kleinen oder einen großen Buchstaben hat, oder was heißt ein großen Unterschied, macht einen Unterschied. Und auf Mac, in HFS schon im Fallsystem, und damit natürlich auch wiederum auf AFP, was da daraus hervorgegangen ist, ist es zwar egal, ob ich einen kleinen oder einen großen Buchstaben verwende, wenn ich auf den Dateinamen zugreife, aber er wird schon unterschiedlich gespeichert.
Man sieht es immer noch.
Man sieht es im Dateinamen, aber es ist egal, wie ich darauf zugreife. Und wie hat sich das jetzt entwickelt, sagtest du? Also jetzt machen sie das auch alle so?
Nein, also UNIX- oder NFS-Varianten gehen dann meist auf die unterliegenden Datalsysteme ein. Wie zum Beispiel das UNIX-Filesystem, das auf dem Server dann verwendet wird. Das ist case-sensitiv. Generell lande ich eigentlich überall. Im Mac OS, was ja inzwischen auch UNIX-basierend ist, gibt es die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Filesysteme zu verwenden. Wenn ich zum Beispiel unter dem Mac ein Volumen formatiere mit UFS, mit dem guten alten BSD-style Fast File System, dann habe ich auch case-sensitiv im Normalfall. Und bei HFS gibt es heutzutage auch eine Option, ob es case-sensitiv anlegen will oder case-insensitiv. Und je nachdem verhalten sich dann auch die Filinger zugriffe.
Das hängt mehr von dem dahinterliegenden Datalsystem ab, weil das macht das Protokoll dann nicht selber. Oder gibt es einfach nur ans Betriebssystem und was auch immer das Betriebssystem entscheidet, ist dann richtig. Das heißt, als du sozusagen Apple Share jetzt unter UNIX gemacht hast, bist du ja sozusagen gegen die Wand gelaufen.
Ja, da haben wir dann auch wirklich die einzige große Inkompatibilität zum originalen Fileserver gehabt, weil wir waren nämlich fast immer case-sensitiv.
Ach so, verstehe. Da musste man dann einfach mit leben.
Ja, das war aber auch in... Es war eigentlich nicht mit irgendeinem Performance-Sache irgendwie einzukaufen. Es war so brutal, viel mehr Arbeit wirklich case-sensitiv zu sein, oder case-preserving und nicht case-sensitiv zu sein, dass wir es mit den damaligen Ressourcen einfach nicht implementieren konnten. Das ging nicht. Es war also von vornherein immer die Frage, können wir es implementieren? Und ich hab dann immer gesagt, nein. Das ist so, ich will das nicht.
Es bringt uns nichts und es bringt uns in die Hölle. Genau. So, jetzt zurück zu SMB. Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, AFP ist von Anfang an offen dokumentiert gewesen. Das kann man von SMB nicht gerade behaupten, oder?
Nee, das war schon immer mit Non-Disclosure. Ich glaube damals sogar schon unter IBM-Regierung war das mit einem Non-Disclosure nur zu bekommen zur speziellen Entwickler-Unterschrift, ich kriege morgen noch einen Kühlschrank oder so, Bedingungen. Und alle anderen Protokolle waren frei offen lesbar. Und dann Microsoft, die dann ja später die Sache übernommen haben, dadurch, dass dann halt IBM vom Betriebsindektor mit OS halb ein bisschen weg war, hat ja dann die ganze SMB-Geschichte in den Windows-Systemen eigentlich eher von Microsoft weitergepflegt worden. Die ganzen Erweiterungen sind von Microsoft eingepflegt worden. Das war alles...
Das heißt von IBM gab es nur diese erste Version eigentlich? Und alle anderen Versionen, die du vorhin angesprochen hast, war alles Microsofts Werk?
Genau. Und das war alles steng geheim, wurde nicht mitgeteilt und war nur die Reverse-Engineering zu bekommen. Also die Sammergruppe mit den Leuten aus Australien, die ja uns diesen freien SMB-Server geliefert haben, die haben entsetzlich viel Reverse-Engineering betreiben müssen, um dieses Protokoll herauszufinden, wie es funktioniert. Es gab da so ein paar Dokumentationen von IBM, wie die Anfangssache funktionierte. Da war IBM auch noch relativ freizügig. Aber dann Microsoft, da war es dann Feierabend. Da war nichts mehr rauszubekommen. Bis zu diesem Gerichtsurteil, wo die EU Microsoft zur Freigabe der Protokolle gezwungen hat.
Und jetzt ist es auch so weit.
Es ist wohl auch zugänglich, ja.
Das heißt, sie haben jetzt alles veröffentlicht, was man wissen muss, um alle Versionen, die es bisher gab, zu implementieren?
Ja, deswegen sind ja auch die Dokumentationen so entsetzlich dick.
Das heißt, ist das im Sommerprojekt jetzt eigentlich schon eingehört?
Weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht mitdienen.
Aber hattet ihr nicht auch so einen Samba-Server bei euch im Paket?
Nicht Samba, aber wir nennen ihn auch SMB-Server. Der war ursprünglich noch vor der SMB-Zeit ein Propietärer, Redirektor eher im Novell-Style. Und zwar wir haben damals für MS-DOS, also noch vor Windows, vor Windows 3.11, Redirektoren gemacht, sei es nun Novell, Banyan Vines und so weiter, die über ihre eigenen Protokolle MS-DOS-Calls übersetzt haben auf die entsprechenden File-Sharing, immerhin zu UNIX. Und wir hatten ein Produkt, das MS-DOS-File-Sharing zu UNIX anbot, vor der Windows-Zeit, also auch vor SMB.
Und vor SMB, und euer eigenes Protokoll. Ah, verstehe.
Das ist auf meiner...
Dein Mist gewachsen.
Ja, leider.
Du bist nicht glücklich mitgewollt.
Das war damals auch ein Local Area Network-Protokoll, war auf UDP-basierend, auch ähnlich wie NFS, und hat nicht fürchterlich berücksichtigt, dass das nicht auch mal über Router gehen sollte. Hat dieselben Macken. Also es war wirklich ein pures, lokales Kabelprotokoll.
Ein Hack, wie man so schön sagt.
Ja, vielleicht.
Ja, zurück zu Samba nochmal, bzw. SMB. Heute sagt man ja eigentlich nur noch Samba. Also jetzt ist das dokumentiert. Was gibt es denn, ist denn sozusagen seitdem es dokumentiert ist, fließt, also ist diese Dokumentation von der Gemeinde da auch schon gelesen und die entsprechende Änderung eingepflegt worden?
Ich glaube nicht. Also was wir als SMB-Server sehen, sind die SMB 3, die Samba 3-Versionen. Und die sind ja noch voll im Ruhigwerksengineering entstanden. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit jetzt die Samba-Gruppe mit dem neuen SMB-Server, Samba 4-Server, Zugang zu den Protokoll-Dokumentationen hat. Ich glaube wohl schon, inzwischen, zumindest Firmen haben das jetzt ohne Probleme mit dem Zugang, die können jetzt so nachgucken und können dann also sehen, wie es wirklich implementiert ist.
Muss man jetzt noch irgendwas unterschreiben, um an diese Dokumentation ranzukommen, oder sind die einfach da?
Die sind jetzt einfach da.
So, die Version, die du jetzt genannt hast, beziehungsweise auf Samba, nicht auf SMB.
Samba 3, Samba 4. Auf die Implementation des freien Servers, der das SMB-Protokoll implementiert. Und wir hatten also auch so eine Variante von dem Server, dieser original, proprietäre Server, nannte sich PC-Share damals, oder heute noch so, enthielt dann also auch ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, als das SMB-File-Sharing im Windows eingebaut war. Als es nicht mehr opportun war, seinen eigenen Redirektor mitzubringen und die ganze Systemqualitätstelle umzubiegen. Dann hat man eben halt auf SMB aufgesetzt und hat dann also auch SMB emuliert.
Das heißt, ja, das heißt, die eigentliche Schwierigkeit bei SMB ist, es ist nicht dokumentiert und man hat auch immer gleichzeitig mit mehreren Versionen rechnen müssen oder wie muss man das verstehen? Oder mit unterschiedlichen Profilen?
Ja, mit unterschiedlichen Versionen.
Weil verschiedene Versionen gibt es ja auch bei AFP.
Ja, aber die waren eigentlich eine so grobere Version. Man konnte sagen, das ist jetzt, ich rede dich mit einem AFP 2.0, ein 2.1 oder ein 3.0 Client. Das war relativ klar.
Das haben die auch gesagt, was sie sind.
Ja, das war bei dem Anmelden, war das klar. Du hast dich, unterhältst dich mit einem AFP so und so Client. Das sieht man bei SMB auch, aber hinterher im Protokoll wird es auch vielfach bei verschiedenen Calls, gibt es die Option, dass ich auch, obwohl ich vielleicht ein neuerer Client bin, um einen neuen Server rede, ich aber in dem Situation, die man Alt und Call verwende.
Ich verstehe, das heißt bei AFP ist das so ein All or Nothing. Also ich bin Version 3, dann habe ich auch alles zu implementieren und dann rede ich auch nur noch 3.
Genau.
Während man bei SMB, bei jedem Call, quasi sich die Versionen aussuchen kann.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt als Programmierer entscheide, ich will jetzt gerade weniger Informationen sehen, dann kann ich in meiner Dokumentation, wenn ich die denn habe, nachgucken ach dieser Info-Level, bei dem Call lieferte genau die Informationen, Subset, den ich jetzt gerade brauche, dann brauche ich ja den großen, mit dem großen Buffern gar nicht anwenden, dann kann ich einen kleinen nehmen. Das ist vielleicht ein 5 Jahre alter Call, das merke ich in dem Moment vielleicht gar nicht. Da gibt sich also ein wirklich barocker Wildwuchs von Calls und das macht die ganze Sache so entsetzlich schwierig, das zu implementieren. Also Samba ist definitiv ein Hightech-Stück des Reverse-Engineerings.
Dass das überhaupt funktioniert sozusagen. Jetzt hast du gesagt, es gibt SMB 2.0 bei Vista. Alles neu?
Ja, alles neu.
Und vorher gab es aber schon dieses CIFS. Wie verhält sich denn das jetzt zueinander?
CIFS ist eigentlich nur eine Marketing-Rebranding.
Von dem normalen SMB.
Genau.
Aber auch keine spezielle Version davon?
Nein, es wurden ein paar Kleinigkeiten in der Verbindungsetablierung geändert. Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so in meiner Erinnerung ist, da gab es mal eine Zeit, wo jeder Hersteller sein Protokoll als Internet-Standard implementieren wollte. Wir machen File-Access über Internet. AFP gibt es über TCP. Das gibt es eigentlich in dem Sinne nicht. Kein Standard. Kein wirklich übergreifendes Standard.
Und deswegen nennen sie es auch CIFS.
Common Internet File System. Es sollte durchgehen als Draft für den generellen Zugriff von Dateien über Internet. Als File-Sharing-Protokoll generalisiert werden. Die wollten das auch gerne durchbekommen. Und das bedeutet, sie mussten ein paar Altlast-Sachen wegbekommen. Und das war die etwas merkwürdige Netbios über TCP-Emulation auf Port 138 und 139, diese Verbindungsaufbau verwendet wurde, wo dann geändert wurde, dass das dann alles über den ZIFS-Port in einem Port abgeben. Weil man musste nur noch von einem Rechner den Port haben, man musste ihm keine Netbios-Geschichten mehr emuliert darstellen. Man konnte dann mit einem Port open an dem Port von dem ZIFS-Port dann eine File...
Und auch erst seitdem gibt es eigentlich die Möglichkeit, jetzt für SMB auch so eine URL zu machen, mit SMB, Doppelpunkt-Server, etc., was ja bei AFP eigentlich schon immer ging. Also spätestens seitdem ist es auf IP-Aufsätze, oder?
Ging es schon immer, ja.
Und bei NFS geht es einfach... Ja, doch geht es auch seitdem, sie über TCP gehen, oder?
Ja, die über TCP gehen. Also das Lokale ging das vielleicht auch schon, aber das wollte man nicht wirklich über Router hinweg verwenden.
Aber so NFS über TCP verwendet auch nur ein Port.
Nur ein Port, genau.
Und könnte dann auch SSL verwenden? Wissen wir nicht.
Ja, glaub nicht.
Gut, aber diese CIFS-Geschichte, das ist ja nichts geworden. Also das ist ja... Hätten Sie nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt dann auch schon das ganze Protokoll dokumentieren müssen?
War ja auch mal dokumentiert. Zum großen Teil waren wir doch mal dokumentiert. Aber es waren nicht alle Varianten definiert, sondern nur das, was Sie jetzt als CIFS von der aktuellen Version definiert haben. Wenn man so nach diesen CIFS-Spezifikationen im Server implementiert hat, dann hat er eigentlich mit nicht vielen Clients reden können.
Ah, es funktionierte einfach nicht. Weil die Clients einfach gesagt haben, ich will aber jetzt mit Versionen sprechen und dann hat der CIFS Server gesagt, okay, nicht, steht hier nicht drin. Alles klar. Oh Gott. Und was ist jetzt neu mit SMB 2.0?
Im Wesentlichen längere Größen für nahe zu alle Sachen. Längere Dateien? Aber längere Partnern, vielleicht längere ID's für viele Transaktionen, wenn man zum Beispiel Read- und Write-Calls machen kann, dass da Limitationen drin sind, wieviel zum Beispiel maximal in einem Read und einem Write über eine Netzwerktransaktion gesendet werden können, um das aufzupalten zu müssen in kleine Calls. Und dann halt die vielen Aufspaltung in verschiedene Info-Levels wurden einfach alle bereinigt. Das Protokoll ist einfach sozusagen...
Es gibt jetzt nur noch ein Level. Sie haben jetzt mal einen Release gemacht, sozusagen.
Das ist sozusagen einmal durchgestylten alles.
Aber das benutzt sozusagen nur Vista und das kann auch nur Vista. Und es gibt auch keinen Backport jetzt zu anderen Windows-Versionen. Aber es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass SMB 2.0 in Samba demnächst einzufällt.
Ja, ich denke wohl in Samba 4 sind da Ansätze für drinnen, wenn ich das so richtig erblickt habe. Aber das ist sozusagen noch alles im Anbeginn der Zeit.
Klar, Vista ist ja noch recht frisch.
Und auf alle Fälle Vista spricht ja auch alle alten Protokolle, weil Vista ist natürlich eine Server-Komponente für die alten Protokolle auch noch drin, die so ziemlich dem von XP entspricht. Und sprich, die können da die ganzen anderen Protokolle auch immer noch reden.
Hast du das SMB 2.0 schon mal so weit angeguckt, dass du sagen könntest, dass das jetzt auch alles kluge Entscheidungen waren, die dir da gefällt haben?
Muss ich passen.
Gibt es überhaupt irgendwelche kluge Entscheidungen in diesem SMB? Gibt es irgendwas, wo das Protokoll jetzt besonders gut ist?
Hm, also ich finde es eigentlich ein Kompromiss, ein elendes Kompromiss.
Und inwiefern?
Wie soll man das sagen? Es geht zu viel auf die Semantik ein von den einzelnen, wie die Dateien zueinander sind. Also man kann zum Beispiel nicht so schön, wie soll man das am besten erklären, in den frühen SMB-Protokollen kann man wenig drinne buffern. Man kann wenig Caching machen, lokal. Und dann gibt es dann die Möglichkeiten mit den Leases, mit den Feilscheren, wo man was machen kann, was recht fragil ist in dem Design. Es gibt viele Entscheidungen in dem Protokoll drin, die auf die früher getroffen wurden. Ob diese in den SMB-2 verbessert worden sind, weiß ich nicht. Dann, wo einfach Constraints der Betriebsstimme früher, früher war der Speicher kleiner, die Pakete kleiner, die Rechenkapazität war kleiner, wo man nicht so viel machen konnte. Heutzutage mit den relativ substanziellen Kapazitäten in den Rechnern selber, die man auf dem Tisch stehen hat, auch dein MacBook, das auf dem Tisch stehen hat, ist ja schon eine beeindruckende Maschine, wenn man das vergleicht mit was es früher sogar gab. Dann ist vielleicht so ein Protokoll wie WebDAV einfacher für Sharing übers Internet. Für hocheffizientes Sharing im lokalen Netz werden diese Protokoll auch weiterhin verwendet, wo es nicht so drauf käme zu großen Overhead zu haben, dass ich also alles übersetzen muss in Mime und hast du nicht gesehen, wo einfach nur die rohen Bytes durchkommen. Das SMB-Protokoll ist in dem Sinne eigentlich schon ein guter Kompromiss, weil es enthält auch mehrere Forks, Multiforks.
So ähnlich wie AFP.
Genau, das wurde ja damals im NT, um einen AFP-Server zu implementieren, mehrere Forks eingeführt.
Ach, deswegen?
Ja, Microsoft hatte auf der To-Do-Liste...
Aber warum wollten sie denn das überhaupt tun?
Die wollten auch Mac-Klines anbinden können an ihre Server. Als der NT-Server kam, war der ja als Server geplant gewesen. Und der sollte auch als Serverbetriebssystem alle möglichen Protokolle sprechen können, auch Apple-Protokolle. Und da wurde auch denen klar, dass man mehrere Forks braucht. Und deswegen wurden auch im NTFS mehrere Forks implementiert.
Also das NT-File-System ist dann im Prinzip gleichgezogen mit HFS an der Stelle?
Ja, es hat also da einige Möglichkeiten sogar mehr geboten als HFS. Es war an der Stelle sogar moderner. Erst die neueren HFS-Plus-Modelle haben da ein bisschen nachgezogen. Und NTFS bietet all diese Möglichkeiten, multiple Forks, Attribute für Dateien, Unique IDs für Files, für Dingensnummern, Möglichkeiten, Alias zu resolven, die in der kurioserweise in NTFS keiner benutzt, außer dem AFP-Server.
Verstehe, also Features, die eigentlich da sind, die eigentlich toll zu nutzen werden, weil es macht ja total Sinn auf dem Desktop.
Ja, also die Link-Dateien von dem Windows GUI, also von der Windows Explorer Shell, die speichern beim besten Willen zum Beispiel nicht eine Nummer ab, die zum Beispiel in NTFS ja auch drin ist. Jedes Datei hat auch ein File-ID, wie auch im AFP verwendet wird. Und man könnte eine Alias genauso Verschiebbare implementieren unter NTFS wie unter AFP, aber das macht man nicht.
Die machen es einfach nicht.
Die machen es nicht, weil es im GUI nicht vorgesehen ist. Das Win32 ist nur ein kleiner Subset von dem. NTFS war als eierlegende Wollmichsauge plant. Es sollte auf dem original NT-Design eine POSIX-Umgebung, also eine UNIX-Emulation machen können. Es sollte möglichst mehrere Serverbetriebssysteme emulieren können. Man konnte ja damals unter dem NT diese verschiedenen Subsysteme verwenden. So eine OS-Halbe-Emulationsgeschichte, eine POSIX-Emulationsgeschichte und die Win32-Geschichte, die Subsysteme. Und diese Subsysteme hatten alle verschiedene Ansprüche an das Dateisystem. Und das NTFS war die eierlegende Wollmichsauge, die da was alles konnte.
Damals haben sie auch noch ein bisschen Einmachs-Fantasien gehabt. Es sollte ja auch auf allen möglichen Prozessor-Plattformen laufen, das NT so importiert werden, was ja dann auch alles wieder eingestampft wurde.
Genau, es lief auf Alpha, auf MIPS und was auch sonst noch so.
Aber daraus ist sowieso recht nichts geworden.
Nee, das hat damals wohl die PC-Revolution mit Intel als marktmächtigen Vertreiber von Systemen ein bisschen verhindert.
Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Aber auch so dieses, wir sind jetzt der Server für alle anderen Systeme, also für UNIX und für den Mac. Kann ich ja auch nicht spüren, dass ich das...
Nein, im UNIX-Umfeld haben sie eigentlich nie richtig den tollen Server dargestellt.
Im Macintosh-Bereich eigentlich auch nicht.
Auch im Macintosh-Bereich ist das ja häufig verwendet worden. Also NT wurde als Server für Macs sehr viel verwendet. Haben wir als Firma, als Produkt damals häufig gesehen im Feld. Wurde häufig verwendet.
Weil der Server eh da war und die paar Macs sozusagen, die noch da waren, die konnte man dann auch noch mit anbinden.
Ja, und weil auch Microsoft damals schon mit ihrer Implementation erstaunlich gut alle diese Systeme zusammen bekommen hat. Es gab erstaunlich wenig Konflikte. Weil vielfach bei dem Zusammenbringen von Systemen mit verschiedener Semantik, wie zum Beispiel Mac oder Windows oder UNIX, hast du so Clashes in der Philosophie, wie zum Beispiel, wie ist zum Beispiel ein File geshared? NFS kennt keine File-Sharing-Modus. Das dreht sich also darum, unter NFS kann jeder ein File öffnen, jeder drauf lesen, jeder drauf schreiben. Und wenn man möchte, kann man sich verabreden über ein Locking-Protokoll, was ja im Original-NFS-Protokoll nicht mal Teil des Protokolls ist, sondern was separat zeitband in einem getrennten Protokoll abgewickelt wurde, kann man auch Byte Range-Locks, also man so einen Range-Lock in der Datei.
Aber da gab es einen expliziten Lock-Server dann dafür.
Lock-Demon, genau. Lock-Demon.
Lock-Demon, mit dem musste man dann irgendwie reden und sagen, hallo, ich würde gerne diese Datei locken. Aber wenn ein Programm einfach den Lock-Server ignoriert und trotzdem drauf zugreift, dann...
Ist ja wie die UNIX-Systemcall-API. Ich muss ja, wenn ich mit den Locks arbeite von UNIX, das Volontär selber wollen. Und die Applikationen mit den Locks arbeiten, können sich synchronisieren, aber ich muss es nicht. Das ist so nach der Maßnahme unter UNIX. Ich will die Mechanismen zur Verfügung stellen, aber sie nicht forcieren. Wenn zum Beispiel jemand das erste Byte vom Password-File lockt, sollte das Password-Login-Programm davon nicht sich stören lassen, weil er sowieso andere Mechanismen verwendet. Nicht, dass jeder Hans und Franz irgendwie sagen kann, ich möchte das und das jetzt machen. Und in den anderen Betriebssystemen, das wird jedem aufgefallen sein, der mit Windows arbeitet oder der mit Mac arbeitet, gibt es Situationen, wo eine Applikation eine Datei offen hat und es verweigert, diesen Feil zugreifen zu machen für andere. Das ist das Öffnen, exklusiv für Redfreit, für eine Applikation, jeder andere kann nicht mehr darauf zugreifen, dass er Backup-Programme Schwierigkeiten haben. Jeder hat das schon mal unter den Betriebssystemen kennengelernt. Diese Datei lässt sich momentan nicht archivieren, weil sie gesperrt ist.
Das heißt, Locking ist jetzt sowohl bei SMB als auch AFP ein fester Bestandteil?
Ein fester Bestandteil ist immer schon Teil des Protokolls gewesen.
Funktioniert das auch in beiden Fällen identisch?
Es gibt leicht semantische Unterschiede im Byte-Range-Locking und auch in den Sharing-Modes. Was jetzt wie eine Datei geöffnet wird, wie sie per Default Open for Read, Open for Read und Wraith, da gibt es kleine, marginale Unterschiede.
Aber nicht so substanzielle.
Nein, substanzielle, aber NFS fällt da vollkommen raus.
So, jetzt muss ich nochmal ein bisschen zurückspulen, wo wir jetzt eigentlich hergekommen sind. Wir waren halt bei SMB und vor allem jetzt SMB 2.0 bzw. wie Microsoft das früher so mit dem Samba so gehalten hat. Ich meine, dass sie dann einen guten AFP-Server implementieren konnten, ist insofern nicht überraschend, als das AFP halt wohl dokumentiert war. SMB war es nicht. Jetzt sagst du, mit SMB 2.0 ist das anders. Das heißt, das ist jetzt auch dokumentiert.
Ich glaube, das ist wohl auch Teil dieses Dokumentationspaketes.
Sie haben jetzt eingesehen, dass es vielleicht mal eine gute Idee wäre, das zu dokumentieren, weil sie einfach ihren Kunden eigentlich auch nicht länger zumuten können, dass alle mit unausgereifter Software darauf zugreifen. Weil es gibt ja so viele...
Diese Akkumentation, die unterstellt eine Denke, glaube ich, die bei uns vorliegt, aber nicht unbedingt bei Microsoft.
Ja gut, aber was ist mit diesen ganzen Appliances, die jetzt heutzutage rauskommen? Ich meine, es gibt jetzt zahlreiche Festplatten, die kommen serienmäßig mit SMB-Support daher.
Ja, aber diese Appliances im Microsoft-Umfeld sollten natürlich mit Windows NT Embedded fahren. Dann ist jetzt ja gar kein Problem. Du musst es mit einer anderen Brille...
Windows NT Embedded, aber das nutzt doch niemand.
Es hat es gegeben. Es gab Appliances, die mit einem Embedded NT geliefen. Ich weiß gar nicht, welchen Firmen das war. Es gab Appliances, die im Netzwerk auf waren, die waren mit einem Embedded NT. Also es gibt dieses Konzept und die Microsoft-Brille sieht dann manchmal ein bisschen anders aus. Du musst manchmal große Firmen anders angucken, als wenn du als Privatperson dahinter guckst. Das sind ganz andere Brillen.
Ja gut, ich meine, dieses mit proprietären Protokollen, da ist ja auch Apple nicht gefeit. Wenn ich mal zum Beispiel iTunes, das DAAP-Protokoll, mit dem man halt auf die Musiklibrary zugreifen kann, das erinnert sich halt auch am laufenden Meter. Auch da gibt es halt Lizenznehmer. Insofern, klar, das gibt es dort auch. Bloß beim Falsch-Sharing finde ich es so ein bisschen die falsche Stelle, also vielleicht generell eigentlich die falsche Stelle.
Ja, aber ich glaube, es kommt im selben Zuge in der Denke. Es soll halt alles zu dem eigenen Vorteil generieren. Es soll also ein Login, ein Wendelogin stattfinden. Und der Wendelogin findet am besten statt, wenn man alles, was passiert, möglichst geheim hält.
Aber ist Microsoft bei SMB nicht selber gegen die Wand gelaufen? Ich meine, mit diesen zahlreichen Versionskombinationen, die es da gibt, das ist doch tödlich.
Ja, das ist definitiv eine Falle gewesen, weil die haben bestimmt einen extremen, unangenehmen Testaufwand gehabt für ihre eigenen Server. Also, das wird nicht angenehm gewesen sein. Und es gab da ja so Ansätze zu sehen, wenn man sich diese CIFS-Sessions von der Storage Networking Industry Association angeschaut hat. Da gab es solche Sessions, wo dann wesentliche SMB-Server-Hersteller, die z.B. historische Systeme, EMC war da immer vertreten, auch einer der Sponsoren, NetApp war da und alle anderen Firmen, die solche Philer-Systeme angeboten haben. Und da wurde eben halt dann ein Interoperability Lab gefahren, wo dann diese riesen Schränke von EMC standen und dann Leute mit ihren Clients davor standen und versucht haben, mit diesen Schränken zu sprechen.
Um mal zu gucken, ob das überhaupt noch alles miteinander läuft. So ein bisschen wie diese Sync-Feste bei SyncML und so weiter.
Ja, das ist der selbe Grund. Es gibt ja auch, NFS gibt es sowas ähnlich auch. Die NFS-Leute machen ja auch mit ihren verschiedenen Implementationen solche Shootouts, wo sie versuchen Interoperability festzustellen und die Kinken rauszumachen.
Okay, jetzt gibt es SMB 2.0 und es bleibt nur zu hoffen, dass bei einer brauchbar offenen, also ich meine, er heißt offend dokumentiert, dass es dann auch jeder implementieren darf oder haben die da nochmal irgendeinen Copyright vermerkt draufgemacht? Du weißt es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht, tut mir leid.
Das werden wir noch rauskriegen. Find ich auf jeden Fall schon mal eine interessante Information und es wäre durchaus zu wünschen, dass dort vielleicht auch noch so ein paar andere Probleme gemacht werden. Weil ich muss sagen, ich hab mit SMB eigentlich immer eine Menge Ärger. Also Zugriff auf SMB, das wäre vielleicht auch nochmal eine Frage, wie funktioniert denn die Authentifizierung da? Irgendwas ist da anders?
Ja, das ist also die NT-Hash, oder wie heißen die dann vielleicht, diese gehashten Passwörter. Und zwar, damit die Passwörter nicht im Klartext über das Netz gehen, werden sie mit so einem Zerrkungsalgorithmus zerstückelt. Und dieser Zerrkungsalgorithmus bedingt, dass man Passwörter in einer bestimmten Form auf Client und Zielmaschine abspeichern muss. Weil man zum Beispiel aus dem Original-Wurst-Passwort, was zum Beispiel bei UNIX üblich ist, zum Beispiel nicht zu einem NT-Hash rückwärts kalkulieren kann. Und da gibt es nur bestimmte Arten, wie man dann Passwörter auf der Server-Maschine auch speichern will. Man will ja vielleicht auf dem Server nicht unbedingt das Passwort des Clients im Klartext speichern. Das war zum Beispiel ein großer Nachteil bei der Variante, die im Apple gehabt hat, mit dem 2-Variant-Nummer-Exchange, deswegen werden heute auch andere Mechanismen verwendet, dass die Passwörter irgendwo mal bekannterweise im Klartext auf der Server-Maschine gespeichert werden müssen. Und das hat man dann mit anderen Diffie-Hellman-Exchange Varianten auch ein bisschen kompensieren können. Aber die NT-Hashes bedeuten auch, dass man auf dem Server ein Passwort in kompatibler Form abspeichern muss, dass man die also auch abbilden kann. Und deswegen hat man ja auch beim Summer-Server das extra SMB-Passwort-Programm, dass man einem User nachträglich noch mal in der SMB-Passwort-Datei ein eigenes Passwort abspeichert, auch wenn man dasselbe Passwort noch mal eingibt und immer synchronisiert. Wenn man sein Passwort ändern will, muss man das nicht mit dem System-Passwort-Programm machen, sondern mit dem SMB-Passwort-Programm, damit der etc-PassWD und auch der SMB-PassWD-File parallel gepflegt werden. Hatten wir...
Ist das nicht ein bisschen anders?
Hat sich bisher nur in der Form nicht ergeben. Also außer du zentralisierst dich mit aktiv Directory und den entsprechenden Mechanismen zentralisiert mit einem Server, dann musst du aber den ganzen Kram drum herum auch implementieren. Da ist ja dann versteckt drinne wieder so eine Kerberos-Variante. Und da gibt es dann Möglichkeiten, das zu machen. Aber für den Heimbedarf ist es ja immer so, dass ich auf jedem Rechner einen User-Namen und ein Passwort eingerichtet habe für den Account. Und was die meisten Leute wohl noch mehr stört dabei ist, dass hier in der Auswahl im Mac waren es ja direkt sichtbar, welche Server sind verfügbar, oder tippt den Namen ein bei der TCP IP-Variante. Bei der SMB-Variante gab es ja immer diese Gruppen, Arbeitsgruppen. Alle Arbeitsgruppen anzeigen, Arbeitsgruppen zeigen. Das ist dieses TCP-basierte NetBios-Naming, was er nochmal drüber legt, was also unterschiedlich ist von dem Naming, was zum Beispiel DNS bietet. Wenig Leute wissen, dass man dieses Ganze umgehen kann und einfach auf der Adresszeile in dem Windows-Browser oben direkt eintecken kann. Backslash, Backslash, hallo.hasel.edu, Backslash. Und dann kommt man direkt bei dem Server. Da kommt man um dieses ganze Browser-Kram drum herum. Weil dieses Browser-Kram, das war auch in vielen Orten instabil und auch wenn du drei, vier Rechner mit verschiedenen Arbeitsgruppen heutzutage direkt zusammenklemmst, dann dauert das bestimmt ein paar Stunden, bis die sich so geeinigt haben, dass man also in diesem Browser sehen kann, wer da ist. Sonst gibt es dann immer ein Timeout und geht nicht und hast nicht gesehen, dass es funktioniert eigentlich relativ schlecht.
Wenn man jetzt sich bei AFP anmeldet, dann ist ja so, ok, also ich benutze, präsentiere jetzt meinen Usernamen, mein Passwort und dann bekomme ich aber als Teil des Protokolls auch schon eine Liste von mir zugänglichen Ressourcen, sprich Fallsystemen.
Nein, du bekommst jetzt mal nur eine Session und der Client kann anhand der Session nummerieren, welche Volumes verfügbar sind für seine Zukunftsberechtigungen.
Ok, aber das läuft jetzt über dieselbe Verbindung.
Dieselbe Verbindung, aber man bekommt jetzt mal eine Session und darüber bekommen die Volumes nummeriert. Das ist bei der SMB so ähnlich. Du bekommst eine Session und du kannst über diese Session dann auch dir die Ressourcen angucken, die der Server hat.
Also da gibt es auch keine konzeptionellen Unterschiede. Das ist eigentlich...
Dasselbe in grün.
Also es wird anders realisiert. Zum Beispiel gibt es dann also auch bei Microsoft die Variante, dass also viel Remote-Procedure-Call und Interprozess-Kommunikation über das Fallsystem abgebildet wird. Weil im Fallsystem von Microsoft, ob es nun über SMB oder localistische NFS, gibt es die sogenannten Named Pipes. Named Pipes gibt es ja auch unter UNIX, aber das bedeutet etwas anderes. Named Pipe unter Windows-Betriebszimmern bedeutet eher etwas wie ein Endpunkt, wie man sie unter UNIX für UNIX-Domain-Zockets verwendet. Einen bidirektionalen, messagebasierenden Kommunikationskanal.
Also ein Kommunikationsport sozusagen.
Genau, das wird über das Fallsystem realisiert. Und über ZIPS ist auch gleichzeitig immer dieses Kommunikationsmodell mit verfügbar. Und da werden dann mit einem RPC-Mechanismus, der abgereitet ist von dem DCE-RPC, was damals von Apollo designt worden ist, und dann reingegangen ist über...
DCE, Distributed Computing Environment.
Genau, das DCE-RPC ist das RPC, was Microsoft verwendet. Aus der HP Apollo-Schiene damals. Einer der wesentlichen Designer von Apollo war lange Zeit derjenige, der bei Microsoft für Protokolle zuständig war. Der Designer von diesen...
Und der hat dann mal das genommen, was er kannte.
Genau. Und das wird dann auch gerne über diese Nebpipes, über die File.io-Protokolle gemacht. Also das bedeutet also, ich brauch keine getrennte Namespaces. Viele Windows-Programme kommunizieren remote über Entitäten, die jetzt nicht direkt sichtbar sind, weil sie versteckt werden, über diese Nebpipes im Filespares. Da wird also angegeben, Backslash, Backslash-Servername, Backslash-Resource-Name. Da wird eine Nebpipe angegeben. Und die wird dann von Programmen gleichzeitig verwendet. Und über das File-Sharing-Protokolle wird gleichzeitig der Remote-Prozedur-Kolle abgewickelt.
Verstehe, das heißt, man kann sozusagen, man hat so eine virtuelle Datei in der eigenen Sichtweite über dieses Sharing-Protokolle. Und wenn man da was reinspuckt, redet man aber nicht mit einem Storage, sondern man redet mit einem anderen Prozess.
Genau. Und diese Nebpipe-Prozesse, die sind sozusagen von Windows-Programmierern eigentlich für gegeben angenommen. Und es wird auf vielfach verwendet. Und das ist in anderen Protokollen nicht der Fall. Es wird nur nicht so, in der Form, nirgendwo so verwendet. Weder AFP verwendet ist, noch NFS verwendet ist, weil ja alle Protokolle mit diesen Portnummern anders geregelt sind. Bei AFP wird es auch anders geregelt. Das ist in dem File-Protokoll mit integriert.
Das macht es natürlich auch noch mal extrem komplex, um das so...
Ja, wusstest du, dass man eine komplette Registrie auslesen kann über das Protokoll, dass man auch einen kompletten Rechner remote administrieren kann, inklusive der Festplattenkonfiguration mit Formatieren, Partitionieren und allem drum und dran?
Was über SMB?
Natürlich.
Deswegen, wegen dieser Namepipes?
Ja, weil alle diese Administrationsinterfaces von Microsoft, alles was du als diese Snap-Ins für die Management-Konsole siehst, geht alles remote über das Namepipe-Mechanismus, über das SMB-Fallsystem.
Und habe ich automatisch immer auf alle Zugriff über jede beliebige SMB-Verbindung? Bei Design?
Bei Design.
Das heißt, wenn ich irgendeine SMB-Verbindung habe, dann kann ich theoretisch auch mit jedem Systemdienst...
Da reden, wenn die Credentials ausreichen.
Also wenn meine Zugriffsrechte als User ausreichen. Aber dann läuft alles nur darüber. Es gibt da keinerlei Fahrtaussperrung nach dem Motto, ich will jetzt hier mal nur Dateien anbieten.
Nein.
Oha.
Ist deswegen auch von der Security ein bisschen unübersichtlich für den Nicht-Eingeweihten.
Würde ich auch meinen. Da wäre ich ja jetzt nicht im Traum drauf gekommen, dass irgendwie so was da in so einem Protokoll mit drin ist. Hammer. Und genau, was mich auch immer noch ein bisschen verwirrt hat, ist die Art und Weise, wie ein Gastzugang abgebildet wird. Also, soweit ich mich erinnern kann, ist ja sowohl in AFP als auch in SMB sozusagen ein Gastzugang auch explizit im Protokoll so vorgesehen.
Ja, es gibt in der Form, man kann es anbieten. Und zwar bei AFP ist es durch das Plug-in-Mechanismen der Authentisierung gegeben, ob man einen Gast Authentisierung zulassen will. Also bei AFP wird es bei der Session Establishment dadurch geregelt, welches Plug-in verfügbar ist. Also die beiden kleinen Server tauschen über Strings aus. Ich unterstütze die und diese Authentisierungsprotokolle in beide Richtungen. Und die einigen sich dann auf eins was beide können. Und eines davon ist auch, ob sie Gastzugang erlauben wollen oder nicht erlauben wollen. Und demzufolge kann man dann bestimmte Sachen in dem original AFP-Fileserver von Apple angeben, dass dieser Guest-User wurde dann in den speziellen Nobody-User oder niemand auf Deutsch übersetzt lokalisiert, gemappt. Und da kann man sagen, ob niemand zugreifen durfte auf bestimmte Folder oder Ordner.
Genau, was ja auch gleich im User-Interface entsprechend produziert wird. Und bei SMB?
Da gibt es ja die Möglichkeit, dass man auch Gastzugang zubereitet. Es gibt ein Gastkonto auf den Rechner, auf den Servern. Und alle Shares, die man als Gast zugreifen kann, kann man auch so zugreifen.
Ist das jetzt eine Eigenschaft des Protokolls oder ist das einfach nur eine Eigenschaft der Windows-Server, die das haben?
Die Eigenschaft der Windows-Server.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt da kein Windows-Server dahinter ist, dann gibt es diesen Gastzugang auch unter Umständen nicht.
Das ist doch auch eine pure administrative Entscheidung, ob ich das zuerlassen will oder nicht.
Ja gut, ich habe mich halt nur gefragt, ob das...
Das ist wie der Gastzugang beim Unix-System.
Ob das jetzt nur so ein well-known user ist?
Nee, ist ein well-known user.
Beim SMB? Und beim AFP ist es aber explizit dieses Gast? Das war das, was ich meinte. Also AFP hat sozusagen wirklich Gastzugang im Protokoll und bei SMB ist es eigentlich eher eine Frage der Konvention und Konfiguration.
Genau. Auch noch ein bisschen der Authentisierung, weil der Gast ja dann auch ohne Passwort reinkommt, dass dann also auch eine Entscheidung gemacht wird, ähnlich wie bei AFP im Vornem, welche Authentisierung wird verwendet. Ich kann auch mit der Gast-Authentisierung, die kein Passwort erfordert, reinkommen. Das aber jetzt gebunden ist in der Administration bei Windows an dem Gastzugang, an den Gast-Account.
Was wir vorhin vielleicht schon hätten mal besprechen sollen, aber was mir jetzt gerade einfällt, das wir so richtig nicht gemacht haben, wie ist denn das eigentlich so mit den Dateinamen selbst, die so verwendet werden? Also wir hatten über Case Sensitivity gesprochen, aber es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr Aspekte. Mir fällt so aus dem Stand erstmal natürlich die Länge ein und auch das Encoding.
Oh, das ist eine Höllengeschichte.
Das ist blutig jetzt, oder?
Das ist richtig blutig, jetzt wird's blutig. Also von der Historie ist es so, ich fange mal mit der AFP an, weil ich das besonders gut kenne. AFP hat begonnen mit den ersten AFP-Protokollen, wo das Fallsystem, die Zeichen, die übertragen worden sind, wurden übertragen im Fallsystem. Also wenn ich einen Mac-Roman-Mac hatte, hat er Mac-Roman abgespeichert im Fallsystem. Wenn ich einen Shift-GIS-Mac hatte, mit japanischen Buchstaben, hat er japanische Buchstaben.
Aber er hat nicht gesagt, dass es das ist, sondern er hat einfach die Werte genommen, so wie sie da kamen.
Richtig.
Und das war auch noch limitiert auf 31 Zeichen Dateinamenlänge, oder?
Ja, das war 31 Zeichen zu Anfang. Und es wurde aber auch übermittelt, es wurde ein solcher ID dafür mit übermittelt. Man konnte diese Pfeilnamentypen eruieren. Also im Protokoll war vorgesehen, welches, zwar im Macintosh-Betrieb, zum Grafen von vorne rein, so ein 16-Bit-lokale ID mit. Der wurde mit übergeben.
Das heißt, er hat nicht einfach nur irgendeinen Byte-String genommen, so wie er jetzt im Fallsystem steht, sondern er hat schön gesagt, Achtung Hoppla, jetzt kommt japanisch, und hier ist die ID für das zu zeichnen, und dann kommt der String, und dann weiß man auch gleich, wie man den zu nehmen hat.
Genau, aber im Endeffekt war es nicht richtig implementiert, in dem Sinne, weil ja der jeweilige Mac mit einem japanischen Betriebstem oder europäischem Betriebstem installiert war, und in den früheren Mac-Betriebsstem konnten die einzelnen Betriebsstem auch nur mit den Sachen zurechtkommen, wie sie da an der Stelle installiert worden sind, und die hatten dann extreme Probleme, wenn du an denselben Server einen europäisch installierten Mac und einen Koi-8 russisch installierten Mac angeschlossen hast. Das war also richtig konfliktbehaftet.
Verstehe, und alles noch sehr 8-bit?
Ja, alles, diese Mac-Romen, Koi-8 oder Shift-GIS, diese Eskipp-Zeichen verwendet für die anderen Sprachen, war es noch vor Unicor-Zeit. Und mit AFP 3 kam dann die Möglichkeit, dann endlich Unicor zu verwenden. Und das war ja eigentlich schon eine ganz gute Idee gewesen.
Aber?
Aber. Apple hat sich jetzt in ihrer unübertrefflichen Weisheit gedacht, wir benutzen in unserem Protokoll die Compost-Unicode. Und zwar eine Variante von Unicode, die sonst niemand verwendet. Laut dem Unicode gibt es Spezifikationen in der Variante decomposed und composed. Und zwar ob ich z.B. die Umlaute getrennt übertrage, als getrennte Zeichen, oder mit dabei. Also ich kann z.B. den Unicode ein Ö darstellen, also O-Dioresis darstellen, als ich demnächst als Zeichen O-Dioresis übermittel, oder als Doppelpunkt gefolgt von einem O. Die Compost. Dann werden alle Diakritics vorweg, also als getrennte Zeichen auseinandergedröselt. Und das Apple-Spezifikation dafür sagt, wir reden mit die Compost-Unicode. Was kein Schwein macht.
Warum macht sie das?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ist das so, damit man...
Es gibt diese zwei Varianten. Da hat jemand die Spezifikation gelesen und sich dann einfach entschieden, wie wir nehmen diese Variante.
Meinst du, dass sie das ohne Hintergedanken getan haben?
Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Einfach so, oh Gott, wir müssen jetzt gleich zum Mittagessen gehen, lass mal irgendwie eine Münze schmeißen. Das ist ja so etwas, was eine Menge Ärger macht mit diesem Decompost-Unicode.
Überall.
Ja, das ist ja auch im Macintosh-Betriebssystem so, wenn man irgendwie häufig, also ich könnte jetzt nicht genau sagen, wie es sich wirklich verhält. Ich merke nur, dass ich da selber immer wieder gegen eine Band laufe. Man kopiert zum Beispiel was im Browser, wo halt ein Öl drin ist, pastet das irgendwo und kriegt dann halt tatsächlich dieses Decompost-Unicode. Also man kriegt dann einen Doppelpunkt und ein O.
Also ganz fürchterlich ist es zum Beispiel zu bemerken, wenn du einen Webserver auf OSX betreibst. Weil ein Webserver greift auf Dateinamen zu. Du siehst zum Beispiel die Datei müller.html. Wie wird müller.html jetzt dargestellt? Jeder normale Mensch nimmt es jetzt an, Müller ist dargestellt durch einen U-Dioresis, das wird dann also umgesetzt, bei dem aktuellen Fontmanfingen UTF-8. Und denkt sich da seine drei UTF-8 bei, also zwei UTF-8-Escapes, die da jetzt rauskommen. Und dann denkt man aber nicht dran, der Macintosh ist ja mit Decompost-Unicode. Also es sind in Wirklichkeit ja zwei UTF-8-Sequenzen, die da kommen zwischen dem M und dem L. Nämlich einmal die U-Diaresis, also die U-Pünktchen, und dann das U, nacheinander. Der Zeichen wird aufgebläht. Und wenn du denn diese UAL tippst und nicht pastest, bekommst du ja auf einem anderen System, das mit Compost-Unicode arbeitet, ganz andere Resultate als im anderen Fall. Gab es auch in Mozilla früher Darstellungsprobleme. Wenn zum Beispiel die Direktorialistings generiert wurden, konnte zum Beispiel Mozilla, also auch die Firefox verwendende Gekko-Maschine, früher bei den Direktorialistings, die Doppelpunkte nicht über das U setzen, sondern die kamen nacheinander. Da hat es immer M-Doppelpunkt-U-Illa. Da gab es ja also früher Probleme. Also das hat Apple einiges getriggert an Buchs, weil das einfach nicht verwendet worden ist von anderen Leuten in dieser Form.
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch die ganze Zeit noch parallel gegrübelt, was wohl irgendwie der Grund sein könnte. Das Einzige, was mir einfällt, ist, dass es in irgendeiner Form einfacher ist, Strings, die jetzt auf Basislatheinzeichen basieren, als solche auch zu erkennen. Was weiß ich, ein Öl wie ein U zu behandeln. Für einen Telefonbuchstab oder was? Aber ich meine, wenn man das machen wollte, könnte man den String ja immer noch sich decomposen und da ein Voodoo drauf machen.
Also mir ist es auch nicht ganz klar, warum es so in dem Fallsystem dargestellt wird. Das wird jetzt mit dem Voodoo dargestellt, damit müssen wir leben. Aber viele Anwender merken das. Es knallt in diese Implementation-Frage oder die damalige Entscheidung, die knallt bis hoch an die obersten Level. Und viele Leute haben das schon gemerkt, diese Problematik.
Ich frage mich, was die Unicode-Jungs dabei gedacht haben, dass sie sowas überhaupt eingeführt haben.
Dass sie beide Varianten angeboten haben? Da kommt dann wieder die Frage, Policy oder Choice? Deswegen, warum X keine Policies implementiert hat und so ein Katastrophen-Windows-System geworden ist, wo alles möglich ist, und dann Windows oder Mac OS mit einem sehr stringenten System nur wenig Choices gelassen haben. Die Unicode-Leute kamen wahrscheinlich aus dem UNIX-Umfeld und haben einfach, wir müssen alles möglich machen.
Ja, da ist was dran. Das könnte fast so sein. Und an der Stelle macht es dann auch Ärger, weil man dann auf einmal mit zwei möglichen Optionen dasteht. Man kann halt zwei Strings nicht mal so eben miteinander vergleichen, weil kann halt so und so sein. Und zwar jetzt nicht nur dieses Transfer-Incoding. Ich will jetzt keinen Podcast- oder Unicode anfangen, aber das ist ja das, was man auch immer häufig noch durcheinander bringt. Es gibt halt Unicode der Zeichensatz und es gibt Unicode die Darstellung des Zeichensatzes. Und sowas wie UTF-8, UTF-16 sind halt unterschiedliche Darstellungen des gleichen Zeichensatzes. Aber dieser decomposed und compost ist ja im Prinzip noch mal eine andere Darstellung für dasselbe Zeichen. Unabhängig von der Darstellung, wie man das jetzt macht. Okay, und wie ist es bei SMB mit den Dateinamen?
Die nutzten schon sehr früh, da gibt es eine Erweiterung, als die NT-Server raus kamen. Eine von den vielen Info-Levels gab es dann die Möglichkeit, dass man Dateinamen nicht mehr in dem früher gelegenen, einfachen, encoding-basierten MS-Ausfallsystem verwendet wurden. Man kann sich so entsinnen wie KeyB, GR und die CodePage.
Dann fangen wir mal lieber an, wie es am Anfang war bei SMB.
Also am Anfang im SMB war es ganz klar wie bei Macintosh. Der lokale PC war installiert mit einer bestimmten CodePage. Jeder kann sich vielleicht noch aus die alten Zeiten entsinnen, wo man im Config-Punkt ist, und wie CodePages konfiguriert werden musste.
Und keiner wusste genau, was das wirklich beeinflusst eigentlich.
Genau, und diese CodePages beeinflussen auch den Zeichensatz, wie er verstanden wird auf dem Netzwerk.
Das heißt, wenn zwei Rechner unterschiedliche CodePages in der Config-Sys drin hatten, dann...
Gab's Mist....
konnten die sich schon gar nicht mehr, Dateinamen nicht mehr lesen gegenseitig.
Genau, und das wurde dann also mit einer späteren Variante des SMB-Protokolls, wo dann NT ins Spiel kam, komplett auf Unicode umgestellt. Microsoft hat ja internen NT vollkommen Unicode-basierend als Redesign gemacht. Das ist also intern von dem internen Layers, die Fallsystem-Darstellung ist alles Unicode. Allerdings bei denen, wenn mich richten, sind 16-Bit Unicode im... überall.
Also UTF 16 meinst du, oder?
Ne, gut als 16-Bit. Nur 16-Bit für die Fallnamen überall.
Das heißt alles, was 32-Bit erfordert, kann man nicht abspeichern.
In der richtigen Sinne war das so, ja.
Aber das sind dann so irgendwie Hieroglyphen und so ein Traum, was man vielleicht auch nicht wirklich als Dateinamen verwenden möchte. Ich glaube, das machen viele, das ist... das macht das nicht HFS auch genauso. Und auch im Ledungsbereich, glaube ich, das ist auch irgendwie auch gar keine schlechte... Gar keine schlechte Entscheidung, sich da mal ein bisschen zu beschränken.
Dann kann Tutti und der Annemund seine Dateien nicht benennen.
Das heißt innerhalb des SMB ist es wieder so eine Sache, man muss halt auf diesen Info-Level gucken für jeden einzelnen Call, ob jetzt hier mit Unicode gearbeitet wird oder nicht.
Ja, es gab dann zum Beispiel solche Varianten. Man kann sich vorstellen, dass innerhalb einer Session im SMB-Protokoll jemand mit codepage-basierten DOS-Kurznamen auf dieselbe Datei zugreift, wie mit Unicode Langnamen.
Innerhalb derselben Session.
Innerhalb derselben Session. Das ist ohne Probleme möglich und wird auch gemacht.
Das wird gemacht?
Ja.
Warum?
Guck dir das doch einfach mal an. Wenn du zum Beispiel Applikationen installierst, z.B. als Pfad innerhalb der System-Pfad-Einstellung für den Pass, den man auch unter Unix kennt, der wird ja heutzutage per Registry global von vielen Programmen mitmanipuliert, dann schreiben Programme einfach den Kurznamen gewürfelt, dass keine Blanks drin sind, in die Registry rein als Pfad, damit sie keine Probleme mit Blanks haben und Escaping. Weil in den Kurznamen keine Blanks zuständig waren. Und da hat das Fallsystem den Schuldigen...
Was denn für Kurznamen?
8,3 Namen. Jede Datei unter NTFS hat zwei Namen. Einen langen Namen und einen Kurznamen.
Die auch identisch sein können, wenn der lange Name kurz ist?
Genau, kurz genug ist.
Okay. Wie wird der Kurzname gebildet, wenn man jetzt eigentlich nur einen langen Namen vergibt?
Da wird dann ein Verkürzungsalgorithmus mit nachher noch laufendem Unifizierungsmechanismus. Das ist diese Tilde 1, Tilde 2, Tilde 32-Geschichte.
Okay, alles klar, da kommt das her.
Das gäbe natürlich auch einem AFP auch, weil AFP anfing mit 31 Zeichen, was das Original weg betrieben hat und dann aufzuhalten.
Gibt es auch eine entsprechende Verkürzung auf 31 Zeichen?
Natürlich.
Und ist das auch so mit Tilde, Schnecke und so?
Je nach Zweibeinflussung verschieden, ja.
Ach so, nee, ich glaub so mit so Hexcodes am Ende kann das sein?
Nee, das war die Logier-Variante.
Ach so, das habt nur ihr gemacht?
Ja, das war aber nicht spezifiziert, wie ihr uns macht. Das wollen wir an jedem selbst überlassen.
Ach so, verstehe, okay. Also Hauptsache man hat irgendwie eine Methode, um einen kurzen Namen zu generieren? Genau. Verstehe. Und das heißt, mit Unicode wurde dann, also dieser lange Name, also mit dieser Änderung mit Unicode in SMB wurden dann auch lange Dateinamen überhaupt erst möglich?
Ich glaube, es gab schon vorher lange Dateinamen.
Und lange war da auch schon 256 Zeichen?
Ja, das ging ziemlich früh los. Aber da wurde die maximale Pfadlänge bei vielen Windows-Applikationen immer noch limitiert. Das sind erwähnt 32 API durch die maximale Bufferlänge, die in vielen Stellen einen Pfad nicht 256 Zeichen überschreiten kann. Der Composite Pfad.
Obaya, das heißt, wenn man zwei lange, ein paar lange Ordner hat, ein paar lange Ordner-Namen.
Ja, also unter das Betriebssystem...
Dann kann man ja nicht drauf zugreifen, oder was?
Der Betriebssystem Kern innen drinnen, unter NT, lässt da beliebig lange Sachen zu. Man kann immer noch mit dem Escape-Mechanismus die alten Sachen umgehen. Es gibt so spezielle Sonderschreibweisen unter Windows, wie man zum Beispiel mit slash, slash, Punkt, slash, oder slash, slash, Fragezeichen, slash, irgendwie gibt es so Sonders.
Backslash wahrscheinlich sogar auch.
Zwei Backslashes, sind das so? Und dann kommt ja normalerweise der Server-Name. Und dann gibt es dann noch spezielle Escape-Zeichensätze, die im Fallsystem von Windows erkannt werden, wie man längere Buffer übergeben kann, oder die wirklich auf die lokale Maschine zeigt. Die sehen eigentlich aus wie eine Server-Schreibweise, aber in Wirklichkeit die sehr lokale Maschine, aber in anderen Konventionen. Da gibt es dann auch beliebig lange Buffer und so. Dadurch gibt es hier eine Applikation zu kennen. Ich kann mit großen Buffern es klar.
Verstehe. Also ich kann beliebig lange Bufade sozusagen machen.
Also prinzipiell lässt das SMB-Protokoll beliebig lange Buffer zu, in den erweiterten Sachen mit Unicode. Und hat da auch im Fallsystem alles mit Unicode gespeichert bei NTFS als Server, oder bei modernen Fallsystemen, bei SMB mit Samba auch mit UTF-8-Darstellung, wenn man das als Konvention einfach nimmt im Linux-Fallsystem.
Das heißt, heutzutage machen eigentlich alle Unicode. SMB macht Composed Unicode. Und der Mac, also AFP, macht Decomposed Unicode. Das ist ja super. Und da vermute ich mal, wird es bei SMB 2.0 wahrscheinlich auch nicht sehr viel anders sein.
Denke ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu den Versionen. Hatten wir da schon darüber gesprochen? Also AFP Version 3.0, ist das so das aktuelle 3.1, 3.2?
Ja, ich bin also in der ganz letzten Version nicht ganz so up-to-date. Schon länger nichts mehr damit gemacht. Aber die letzten Versionen waren dann 3.1, die ich so kannte, und dann 3.2, glaube ich noch.
Ja, aber was sich da jetzt getan hat?
Im Wesentlichen waren das Sachen wie Session-Management, dass man zum Beispiel schnelles Reconnect hat wieder. Das war, glaube ich, bei 3.1 eine wesentliche Featuresache. Dass du deinen Rechner zusammenklappen kannst und dann wieder aufmachen kannst, dass dann ein Reconnect stattfinden kann.
Also Laptop-Support und so etwas.
Disconnected Arbeit mit Reconnecten und demnliche Filehandles wieder re-etablieren.
Obwohl die Rechner sich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen haben.
Richtig.
Was muss dafür gemacht werden?
Die Problematik ist doch die, dein Rechner ist jetzt zum Beispiel zusammengeklappt. Und theoretisch kann ja so etwas sein, dass ein anderer, zum Beispiel die Datei, die du vorher offen hattest, exklusiv offen hat, weil man denkt, dein Rechner ist nicht mehr da. Du hast den zusammengeklappt. Der war ja sozusagen mit einem Schlag nicht mehr da.
Obwohl man das ja auch nicht normalerweise nicht... Also beim Zusammenklappen kann er ja noch mal irgendwas reden mit dem Server, kurz bevor er schlafen geht.
Aber generell ist dieses Disconnecten auch dafür gedacht, dass man Netze kabelrausziehen kann.
Genau, wenn man das Kabel rauszieht, dann können die ja überhaupt nicht mehr miteinander reden. Dann merkt er ja nicht sofort, dass man da ist.
Das merkt er ja nicht sofort. Das merkt er erst anhand der Timeouts in den Protokollen.
So was wie Heartbeats, wie er sagt, ich bin immer noch da.
Werden ja verwendet, zum Beispiel bei AFP sind Heartbeats innerhalb des Protokolls mit dabei.
Das heißt, daran merkt er überhaupt erst mal.
Wenn nichts passiert, über die Session wird noch zusätzlich Heartbeats rübergeschickt, weil das unterliegende TCP-Protokoll zum Teil brutal lange Timeout hat, wo man dann erst nach einer Stunde feststellen würde, dass jemand nicht mehr da ist. Und mit dem Heartbeats, wenn also in den TCP-Output-Cues wirklich bytes sind und hertransportiert sind, auch wenn es nur wenig sind, dann geht die ganze Timeout-Machinerie dauernd und ist innerhalb von kurzer Zeit feststellbar, dass jemand nicht mehr da ist.
Okay, hat auch den Vorteil, dass auch die Router, die da zwischendurch sind, sehen, dass diese Verbindung noch am Leben ist und nicht ihre Verbindung wegschmeißen. Das machen ja manche dann auch immer ganz gerne.
Net-Geschichten.
Net-Tabellen, genau.
Die mit Timemats abgedeckt werden sollen.
Da gibt es so viel ekliges Zeug. Bei SMB gibt es aber keine Heartbeats.
Upsala, da gab es auch Heartbeats. Gab es auch. Aber es wird aber meist anders implementiert. Es wird also regelmäßig was hin und her geschickt.
Und für diesen Reconnect ist dann was erforderlich?
Mechanismen erforderlich, wie die Möglichkeit, die offenen Files wiederherzustellen und die File-Positionen. Protokolle wie z.B. AFP und SMB haben ja einen gescherrten State. Darüber sind wir noch gar nicht eingegangen. NFS ist ja stateless, während AFP und SMB sind beide statefull. Das bedeutet, der Server weiß ganz genau, was der Client gerade tut. Und der Server hat auch eine Session offen, wo er sich sozusagen lokal merkt, welcher Client hat wie viele Files offen, wo sind die positioniert im File-System, welche Logs sind da drauf offen und so weiter und so fort.
Also das ist statefull, das heißt, es gibt sozusagen einen spezifischen Zustand, die die Arbeit des Clients beim Server hat und der Server weiß davon.
Der Server weiß, welche Files offen sind. Er weiß, welche Files sind offen, er weiß, welche Logs sind offen, er weiß, welche Direktoren da so nummeriert worden sind. Also es gibt nämlich jede Menge Status, die das Server per Client hat.
Okay, und dann ist die Netzwerkverbindung weg, es kommen keine Hardbeats mehr, der Server denkt irgendwann, der ist weg und vergisst ihn.
Ja, aber er muss ihn nicht vergessen, er kann ihn zum Beispiel noch aufbewahren. Und wenn er zum Beispiel einen Reconnect bekommt von dem Client, und er kommt zum Beispiel in eine neue Session rein, und dann kann er zum Beispiel die alte Session übernehmen. Und wenn das Mechanismen übernommen wird, ich würde zum Beispiel alle offenen Files und alle Logs, die von der alten Session herumliegen, die hätte ich gerne wieder.
Aber wie authentifiziert er sich denn dann in dem Moment?
Über die Authentifizierung über den User.
Das heißt, er muss sich dann schon nochmal richtig einloggen?
Ja, er macht einen kompletten Relogin, hat eigentlich eine komplett neue Verbindung offen und damit weiß der Server, ich bin ein authentisierter User. Und dann guckt er sich an, ich habe früher diese Session gehabt und ich bin aber abgebrochen worden, kannst du dann noch was von recoveren? Und dann sagt der Server, oh ja, da habe ich noch was von, da kann ich dir die offenen Files geben.
Und diese Session identifiziert sich auch nochmal über eine Session-ID? Ah, das ist sozusagen dann auch der Unterschied. Und dann funktioniert das auch dann, ich meine, was ja auch noch so ein Grund ist, für einen Disconnect, ist, was wir hier immer haben, diese ekligen Disconnects von DSL-Providern.
Von der Telekom?
Ja, nicht nur von der Telekom, das machen auch andere Provider, das ist allseits beliebt, um, keine Ahnung, die Kunden zu verstören.
Ich glaube nur einfach, um zu kennzeichnen, dass es TTSL, zum Beispiel bei Telekom, war es ursprünglich so, ob es TTSL-Raum oder Business ist. Bei Business gibt es keinen Ricks Connect und bei TTSL-Raum ja.
Ich denke, es geht im Wesentlichen darum, alle Leute zu Privatanwendern zu machen, die nicht so viel von ihrem Internet fordern sollen. Und man kann ja dann Business-Tarif bestellen, da hat man das nicht. Es gibt da, ich werde jetzt nicht zu sehr darauf eingehen, aber Alice macht das auch und so weiter. Es gibt ein paar, die machen es halt nicht, QSC und so, aber die haben halt auch gleich höhere Preise. Das ist auf jeden Fall eklig, aber sowas findet eben statt. Das heißt, der Provider beschließt jetzt einfach mal Disconnect und gibt einem dann halt im schlimmsten Fall auch noch eine andere IP-Adresse. Womit man ja dann, gerade wenn man über NAT geht, dann auch bei diesem Reconnect über eine andere IP-Adresse kommt.
Richtig, und das mit dem Übernehmen ist eher an den User-Credentials gebunden. Ich könnte auch, wenn ich wollte, mit meinem Laptop disconnecten, an einen Netzwerkstrang gehen und connecten und meine alte Session wiederbekommen, weil das ist ja meine Session.
Das ist sozusagen bei AFP mittlerweile auch exzellent dabei.
Ja, das ist eine von den Protokoll-Revisionen im 3er-Bereich.
Gibt es sowas Vergleichbares auch bei SMB?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Es gibt dieses Distributed File System, Teile, wo sowas mit dabei sind, aber ich bin nichts darüber im Klaren. Vielleicht gibt es das unter SMB 2, da muss ich passen. Da bin ich nicht so gut informiert.
Aber ist auf jeden Fall so ein AFP, irgendwie Apple Laptop Feature.
Ich meine, das ist ein User-Experience-Ding. Das haben die gemerkt mit dem Zusammenklappen des Rechners passiert ganz gruselige Sachen mit meinen Sessions, die irgendwo unten drin sind.
Vor allem da hängt dann auch der ganze Scheiß immer und das will man ja auch nicht, weil dann auch Retries kommen und so.
Ja, das Hängen ist ja wohl typischerweise die NFS-Eigenschaft, ne?
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt auch nochmal erwähnen. Also, NFS kennt diesen State nicht. Nein, gar nicht. Also grundsätzlich nicht, das heißt der Server weiß nie irgendwas über den Client. Und das hat den Vorteil, dass man aber auch zwischendurch mal den Server quasi neu booten kann.
Richtig, das war wahrscheinlich auch der Grund. Ja, genau. Die ersten Versionen waren wohl nicht ganz so stabil, sondern man musste zwischendurch mal den Server rebooten und trotzdem noch einigermaßen den Service herstellen. Man muss halt ein bisschen warten, bis der Server wieder oben ist und dann geht's weiter.
Ich glaube, das UNIX-Haters Handbook hatte dazu diesen schönen Untertitel, und ich bin mir sicher, dass es deine Files korruptiert.
Das mit dem Korrupten der Files ist ja wohl eine Eigenheit, die dann also liegt an dem wahrscheinlich buggy Server, warum er rebooted hat im ersten Schritt sozusagen.
Ja, hat nicht unbedingt was mit dem Stateless zu tun. Das heißt, NFS ist Stateless, Server und Client wissen nichts voneinander, hat den Nachteil, dass der Server da sozusagen nicht so eine Sache wie ein Fast, ja gut, ein Fast Reconnect, in dem Sinne gibt es ja dann sowieso, weil man connectet halt einfach, ich connecte hier gar nicht. Ich greife einfach zu. Eigentlich müsste eigentlich eine andere Kategorie von Fallserver, Protokoll, oder?
Aber nicht wie NFS v4. Wenn du jetzt NFS v4 anguckst, was sie jetzt gemacht haben, NFS v4 hat jetzt, weil sie ja gemerkt haben, Stateless hat nicht nur Vorteile, Stateless hat auch Nachteile. Ich kann z.B. Recordlocking und File-Sharing-Modes nicht anständig übertragen, weil das wurde ja immer über Seitenprotokolle außerhalb des NFS-Protokolls verwaltet. Das RPC-Lock-Di- und Stadt-Di-Protokoll, was also diese ganzen Locking-Geschichten geregelt hat, das ist vollkommen getrennt und das muss dann doch wieder mit Stateful-Mechanismen gemacht werden. Weil im Entwick wollen die Leute ja irgendwie File-Sharing machen.
Das heißt, NFS 4 ist im Prinzip jetzt eigentlich ein richtiger Contender auch als Alternative zu AFP und SMB.
Es enthält zum Beispiel so etwas wie Extended-Attribute. Es enthält solche Sachen wie die Möglichkeit, State auf der Serverseite zu haben. Das File-Sharing und die File-Sharing-Modes und das Record-Locking ist implizit im Protokoll jetzt mit drin. Es ist nicht mehr extern. Man hat sich von einem Marketing-Message gelöst, der steht, Full ist harmful. Des Weiteren sind sich Sachen drin wie... Mappings von User-IDs und Gruppen-IDs über Strings. Dass man also nicht dasselben ID-Spiel auf jedem Rechner haben muss. Andere Authentisierungsmechanismen sind wohl jetzt auch neuerdings mit drin. Dass man jetzt diese GSS API mit Kerberos-Mechanismen, also Möglichkeiten hat, mehrere Plug-In-Mechanismen für Authentifisierungen zu benutzen. Die genaue Erkundung kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Da fragen wir mal, wie es eine Mölle habe, aber ich habe das schon mal gesehen, GSS API.
NFS V4 setzt das da voraus, die da verwendet wird, um die Authentifisierung über NFS V4 zu machen. Kann ich dir jetzt nicht so viel sagen, aber da wird dann auch mit Kerberos integriert und allem drum und dran.
Okay, also wir gehen mal davon aus, sichere Authentifisierung und dann eben auch über SSL definitiv eine verschlüsselte Verbindung wahrscheinlich auch möglich, oder? Dass man irgendwie NFS auch über SSL macht?
Könnte man immer machen, konnte man auch vorher schon machen. Man konnte ja TCP vermachen, da konnte man SSL-Layer drüber legen. Hat das nicht so sehr viel geändert. Könnte man machen. Man hat es ja dann auch über eine einfache Secure Shell auch remote gemacht. Du konntest ja auch über eine Secure Shell SSH, dein gutes 2049er NFS Port tunneln und dann...
Ja gut, aber das muss man von Hand machen. Es ist natürlich auch schön, wenn so was im Protokoll explizit mit drin ist. Die Zertifikate spielen da ja auch noch mit Rollen.
Könntest du NFS V4 dann wieder mit dabei sein? Müssen wir nachgucken.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Also ich hab mich da immer mit der lokalen Variante beschäftigt und das spricht also mit Performanta lokaler Kabelausnutzung.
Klar. Ja, das bringt uns dann sozusagen zum vierten Player in diesem Spiel. Ist auch schon ein paar Mal jetzt gefallen. WebDAV ist ein Protokoll, was sich anschickt, eben da, wo bisher AFP oder SMB nur eingesetzt werden konnten. Aber eben, wie wir schon gehört haben, auch mit vielen Nachteilen, Protokollaufwand und so weiter und nicht so richtig die Eignung fürs Internet haben, wo das nicht so zum Einsatz kommen kann oder weil es undokumentiert ist oder warum man es auch sonst immer nicht verwenden möchte oder weil es keinen ordentlichen Server gibt. Gibt es jetzt WebDAV, was so viel heißt wie Distributed and Authorized, nee nee, es hat was mit Autoren zu tun und Authoring and Versioning.
Und Versioning ist完全 Delta, weil das 70.000.000.000 Delta-V-Protokoll mit dabei.
Das heißt, man hat dort explizit Zugriff auf Dateien eigentlich vorgesehen, aber auch schon mit der Vision, dass man auch so eine Versionierung gleich mit in das Protokoll mit einfließen lässt, analog zu solchen Versioningsachen, wie sie in der Entwicklung verwendet werden, wie CVS oder Subversion, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Richtig. Obwohl ich jetzt mir nicht bewusst bin, ob irgendein DAV-Server so etwas auch tatsächlich als Feature anbietet.
Tut er. Du musst nur Subversion in deinen Apache mit reinkompilieren, dann bietet er auch DAV an und dann das Delta-V auch. Also nicht ganz komplett, aber das ist zum Beispiel so, du kannst dann auf SVN-Filesystem, also in Subversion abgebildete Repositories, die über dein Apache eingeblendet werden in den ganz normalen URL-Space von deinem Server, kannst du mit diesem WebDAV-Protokoll zugreifen und mit Versionierung. Wenn du zum Beispiel WebDAV-Client zeigst, wie zum Beispiel das einfache Microsoft Office oder dergleichen, die auch mit WebDAV arbeiten können und versionieren können, wenn die ihren File speichern, kriegst du automatisch neue Versionen in SVN.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, DRV ist sozusagen auch ein alternatives Zugriffsprotokoll auf so Sachen wie Subversion?
Richtig.
Ohne, dass sie im Subversion-Protokoll sprechen müssen?
Richtig. Genau, um das mal von vorne nach unten ein bisschen aufzudröseln, ist WebDAV eine Erweiterung des HTTP-Protokolls. Das HTTP, das überall verwendet in Hypertext-Transfer-Protokolls, das wir in allen UNLs vorweg tippen, wo wir inzwischen schon gar nicht mehr wissen, wie man das schreibt, ohne dass man es aus den Fingern rauskriegt. Warum schreiben wir eigentlich HTTP? Aber na gut. Und dieses HTTP-Protokoll ist ja ein recht einfaches, zeilenorientiertes, ASCII-textbasierendes Protokoll, was in guter alter Internet-Mannier definiert worden ist, vollkommen jenseits irgendwelcher Systeme, die es implementieren. Also es wurde nicht mit dem Kopf auf einem Macintosh sitzend oder auf einem Windows-PC-Sitzend oder auf einer UNIX-Workstation designt, sondern es wurde designt vollkommen abstrakt als Protokoll unabhängig von allen anderen Drumherumliegenden.
Die Interoperabilität steht sozusagen vor allem anderen.
Exakte Mann.
Auch wenn das bedeutet, dass man human readable strings drin hat, dass es lang ist, groß ist, schwer ist.
Genau.
Das ist uns egal, dass Local Talk so langsam ist, dann kann man das halt damit nicht benutzen.
So ungefähr, genau. Das ist die Maßgabe. Und dieses HTTP-Protokoll hat ja schon immer innen drinne sogenannte Verben gehabt. Es gab ja sowas wie GET und PUT. Jeder, der mal ein CGI-Programm verwendet hat, weiß schon, dass es sowas gibt wie Zugriffe wie GET, HAT, PUT.
Dieser sogenannte HTTP-Methode.
Die Methode, genau. Die Method. Und da gibt es jetzt in der Erweiterung für WebDAV eben halt noch viel mehr. Da gibt es eben halt auch die Möglichkeit, dass man Rename und Delete und all möglichen anderen Kram und all so einen ganzen Kram noch machen kann. Und das ist eine Erweiterung auf dem ganz normalen HTTP-Protokoll oben drauf. Der beliebteste Vertreter dieser Server ist ja unser lieber alter Apache. Und der dann mit solchen Erweiterungen die DAV-Protokoll noch zusätzlich implementieren, also auch das kann.
Das heißt, man kann dann eben nicht nur eine Datei holen, wie man das jetzt in 99% der Fälle mit dem Browser eben macht mit HTTP. Oder eben auch mal ein Put machen, so für einen expliziten Upload. Posten eines Formulars zum Beispiel kann auch über die Put-Methode erfolgen, auch wenn es interessanterweise auch mit der Get-Methode möglich ist und auch häufig gemacht wird. Aber dafür ist es vorgesehen, eben auch gleich eine andere Methode zu haben. Und darüber hinaus gibt es weitere Methoden, die wenn ein Kleiner das unterstützt, eben auch ganz andere Abstraktionen machen. Wie zum Beispiel nicht, ich will sie nicht holen oder ich will sie senden, sondern ich will sie kopieren, ich will sie löschen, ich will sie umbenennen, ich will sie locken, ich will... Und diese Sachen, die jetzt eigentlich dafür primär, ich weiß ja nicht, was so die Intention war, aber jetzt vom Namen her hat man eben so Zugriff auf Ressource, auf beliebige Art und Weise mit der Unterstützung von Versionierung, hat man dann festgestellt, da kann man ja auch gleich ein Datalsystem draus machen.
Ich denke mal, das war schon...
Das war schon von Anfang an die Intention?
Ich glaube, die Intention war, den Fallsystems-Space eines Web-Servers zugreifbar zu machen, dass man ihn auch mit dem selben Protokoll pflegen kann. Ich glaube, den HTTP-Autoren war es von vornherein ein Dron im Auge, dass alle Leute immer mit einem FTP-Upload ihren Web-Server pflegen müssen. Also mit einem Out-of-Band-Protokoll. Warum kann man das nicht alles in einem Protokoll abwickeln? Und damit ist ja das DAV-Protokoll angefangen, weil damals war es dann möglich...
Eigentlich muss das in die Browser mit rein?
Ja, nicht in die Browser mit rein. Es kam dann in die Filesysteme mit rein. Weil du konntest es unter Microsoft Windows einfach in ein Laufwerk definieren oder in der Macintosh Mac-Betriebssystem mit einer HTTP-URL, ein Filesystem. Da wurde dann DAV verwendet.
Ja gut, aber warum sollte es nicht einfach auch im Browser sein? Wo ich die Webseite sowieso schon sehe...
Aber der Browser war nicht das Autoring-System.
Ja, aber es könnte sein.
Könnte es sein, du meinst Mozilla.
Ja, einfach so einen Edit-Button bereitstellen.
Das ist die monolithische Applikation. Die wollten es auf einer niedrigeren Ebene allen Komponenten im Betriebssystem zur Verfügung stellen, nicht nur den Browser.
Es ist eigentlich nicht nur der Browser, auf jeden Fall auch der Browser, weil dieser Edit-Button ist ja nun nicht gerade verbreitet.
Nö, aber der gute alte Original, der Sea Monkey, heutzutage Sea Monkey, der monolithische Mozilla, der hatte das ja. Der hatte einen eingebauten Editor für HTML-Dokumente, der dann auch so etwas verwenden konnte.
Aber der hat nicht WebDAV verwendet, sondern der hat irgendwie nur Put.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was er benutzt hat.
Er konnte einfach nur Putten. Eine neue Version, da von allem hochladen, sozusagen. Okay, verstehe. Hat man dann rausgeschmissen, weil zu schwer.
Ja, eine monolithische Variante. Sie wollten nicht so viel belasten, eine Applikation haben. Und bei den heutigen File-Sharingmethoden, die verwendet werden, zum Beispiel für einen Shared Storage im Internet, wird ja eigentlich im Wesentlichen jetzt das WebDAV verwendet. Wenn du guckst, zum Beispiel dieses.mec oder mobile.me, oder wie es auch immer jetzt heißt. Mobile.mes, genau.
Weil es nicht mehr funktioniert. Weil es nie funktioniert. Nein, mobile.me heißt es offiziell, also.
Da wird das ja verwendet.
Genau, .mec bzw. die iDisc.
Genau, die iDisc.
Die Internetdisc.
Diese auch in vielen anderen Herstellungen.
Läuft wie bei WebDAV.
Genau, auch viele andere bieten es auch an. Strata bietet sowas ja auch an.
Ja, es gibt so einige Third-Party oder so.
Da gibt es dann auch noch solche Sachen.
Nicht Betriebs-Teamhersteller, die auch solche Sachen machen. Nur Google macht das, glaube ich. Meines Wissens bisher noch nicht, oder?
Nichts, was ich unterlöst habe.
WebDAV-Dienst ist mir neu. Nee, wäre aber mal eine schöne Geschichte.
Ich vermute, dass es das Übung gibt oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Zum Zeitpunkt des Releases dieses Podcasts ist es dann wahrscheinlich schon wieder in Beta verfügbar. Nee, ich habe auch irgendwas klingeln hören, aber ich erinnere es jetzt gerade nicht. Wäre auf jeden Fall gut vorstellbar, weil es ja eigentlich eine logische Erweiterung des Webs ist.
Genau.
Und die Abstraktionen, die diese Methoden herbringen, wenn man das jetzt vergleicht mit den etablierten Fallserver-Protokollen, die wir jetzt besprochen haben.
Das ist vollkommen Löskulle zum Betriebssystem. Du hast ja jetzt den URL-Space. Sie gucken uns diesen Uniform-Resource-Locator oder Uniform-Resource-Namen an, die es da gibt, mit den Schrägern drin, also mit den Schrägern, wie wir sie von UNIX gewöhnt sind, nicht die Rückwärtigen von DOS. Da wird eine eigene Welt mit eigenen Zugriffen, mit eigenen Semantiken dargestellt, die unabhängig ist von den unterliegenden Betriebssystemen. Alle anderen, SMB, NFS und AFP, bringen jeweils auf ihre Protokolle ihre lokalen Betriebssystem-Semantiken mit. Das AFP-freie Protokoll bietet dann also HFS unten an SMB, ZIFS, inzwischen auf ein TFS ziemlich geeicht und NFS hat auf die unterliegenden Fallsysteme, die bei UNIX-Systemen möglich sind. Und diese ganzen Semantiken fallen bei WebDAV weg, weil man geht von der Semantik des Web aus, von der Semantik der Fallnamen und URLs, wie man sie jetzt schon überall findet.
Das heißt diese Resource Forks zum Beispiel, die gibt es da nicht?
Nee.
Aber dafür gibt es Versionen, was die anderen wiederum nicht kennen.
Versionierung gibt es da implizit drin. Obwohl die meisten WebDAVs aber keine Versionierung machen. Erst einmal zusätzlich noch eine Versionierungsengine, die SVN drin hat. Die machen dann auch dieses Delta-V-Protokoll, diese Versionierung. Das ist eine Option bei WebDAV. Man kann also WebDAV anbieten oder WebDAV plus Delta-V.
Gibt es denn diese Forks bei NFS 4 eigentlich?
Als Extended Attributes gibt es das bestimmt. Da gibt es bestimmt wie liebig viele Resource Forks. Wir haben also jetzt auch Support für Extended Attributes und so ein Kran.
Okay, aber WebDAV kennt das nicht. Da gibt es halt eigentlich nur das eine.
Aber lässt sich vielfach emulieren, weil es gibt ja da die Möglichkeiten auch mit verschiedenen URL-Beifügungen hinten an dem Namen. Also der Name einer Datei ist ja im Web nicht so eindeutig spezifiziert wie in einem Filesystem-Protokoll. Da gibt es ja mit Fragezeichen.
Es ist vor allem keine Datei. Es ist eine Ressource. Man beschreibt sie über den Ressourcenamen.
Genau, und da gibt es ja noch Möglichkeiten, was anzufügen.
Das heißt, man macht einfach slash irgendwas und dann kann es schon wieder irgendwas anderes sein.
Man kann es im Kleinen und im Server eigentlich ziemlich transparent beibringen. Das Protokoll bietet eine Menge. Man kann da auch eine ganze Menge drin verklausulieren.
Ist es denn auch performant? Klingt ja nicht so erstmal so mit den großen, schweren HTTP-Headern und so und so.
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Und vor allem ist ja auch der Zugriff da drauf, erfolgt ja zwangsläufig, oder ist das zwangsläufig, immer über eine neue Verbindung. Also wenn ich hier sozusagen irgendwas tue.
Nein, HTTP hat doch schon lange ein Tunnel-Link mit mehreren HTTP-Request auf einer Leitung. Die sogenannten, die wurden nacheinander innerhalb einer HTTP-Seite und mehrere hätte er wieder anfangen neu. Du kannst ja innerhalb belegen, wie das Kippe-Live oder wie man das... Wie diese Kippe-Live-Geschichten. Es gibt ja dann die Möglichkeiten, X-HTTP-Request über eine TCP-Connection abzusetzen.
Aber wer steuert das?
Der Client. Der kann das sicher einrichten, wie es gerne handelt.
Das heißt, der Client connectet und sagt, halt mal gleich offen.
Ja, nee, der hält sie einfach offen und der Server kann nur intervenieren und kann sein Veto geben, indem man ihm hinten in dem HTTP herholt und sagt, close.
Das heißt, auch wenn ich jetzt so eine IDIS-Count über WebDAV schreibe, dann bleibt diese eine TCP-Verbindung die ganze Zeit stehen und es geht die ganze Zeit hin und her. Trotzdem hat man aber immer noch diesen Header-Overhead.
Jedes Mal der Header zwischendurch. Also der Overhead ist wesentlich größer.
Auch wenn ich ein Byte schreibe, übertrage ich erstmal ein Kilo Bytes, User-Agents und was nicht alles.
Genau, es ist ein riesengroßer Overhead dabei. Und auch solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel die Byte-Ranges sind ja eher nachträglich eingebaute Sachen in dem HTTP-Protokoll. Weil es gibt ja diese Accept-Ranges-Methode und diese Byte-Range-Request-Methode, dass man also von einer HTTP-Resource, die man so kennt, auch nicht nur die ganze Ressource abrufen kann, sondern auch Teile. Als wesentlicher Benutzer ist glaube ich aufgefallen, Adobe mit seinen PDF-Produkten, wo die dann innerhalb von PDF-Dateien schon die erste Seite dargestellt haben, wenn in Wirklichkeit noch der Rest nachträglich nachkamen.
Oder diese ganzen Speed-Downloader-Programme, die sich dann immer auf bestimmte Bereiche beziehen.
Die einfach einen Aufsetzen wieder ermöglichen. Denkt zum Beispiel an Vigette mit der Strich-C-Option von der UNIX-Kommandoteile. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen HTTP-Request wieder aufsetzen will und den Rest nachladen will. Also alle Download-Manager, die Reste nachladen, benutzen das. Oder auch solche Sachen wie der PDF-Plugin im Browser, der dann halt Teile von der PDF-Datei nur anschließen will. Das verzeichnet dann die erste Seite, die zweite Seite und so weiter. Und bei WebDAV ist es natürlich noch viel mehr.
Was sagt der Client da eigentlich, wenn er diesen Range spezifiziert? Ist das dann nochmal ein extra Header?
Das ist nochmal ein extra Header, die da übergeben werden. Welche Ranges er haben will. Accept Ranges ist dann dieser Header, dass er auch Ranges akzeptiert, weil es gab auch alte HTTP-Server, die keine Ranges konnten. Es wird dann alles wie bei dieser ASCII-Header abgewickelt.
Was ja vielleicht ein bisschen bloatet ist, aber was auf jeden Fall immer Raum für Erweiterungen bietet, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Interessant ist dabei, dass bei WebDAV von vornherein jetzt ein Metadaten-Kanal von vornherein über das HTTP-Protokoll schon vorgegeben ist, nämlich dass der MIME-Type von jeder Ressource immer vom Server, dem Client, bekannt gegeben wird. Was sonst ja nicht so üblich ist.
Darf er das nicht weglassen? Nein, MIME-Type ist eigentlich...
Wenn du Internet Explorer verwendest, vielleicht. Dann redet er anhand des Lufixes, was es von MIME-Type sein könnte. Aber jeder normale Browser richtet sich nach dem MIME-Type, den der Server sagt.
Hoffentlich. Ja, wenn der MIME-Type irgendwie sinnvoll ist. Server liefern ja auch nicht unbedingt immer sinnvolle MIME-Types.
Ja, sieht man dann, wenn das Ding plötzlich abgespeichert werden soll, als Octet Stream. Wenn man diesen Typ von...
Ja, wenn überhaupt, wenn es nicht irgendwie text-plain ist.
Und in den Browser reinsammelt.
Ja, so ein Apache ist halt defaultmäßig so konfiguriert, dass was er nicht kennt, ist halt text-plain, was wirklich einer der größten Bugs im Internet ist. Was dann immer dazu führt, dass wenn man mal irgendein, was weiß ich, irgendein Firmware-Binary auf irgendeinem Web-Server liegt und dann endet das Ding halt auf Punkt bin oder irgendwie Punkt keine Ahnung. Was halt dann dieser Web-Server vielleicht nicht kennt, dann ist es halt Text-Plane, was dann wiederum dazu führt, dass eben diese Binary, das hat auch jeder bestimmt schon mal gehabt im Web-Browser, wenn man es draufklickt, nicht runtergeladen werden, sondern angezeigt werden, dann kann man das nicht mal abbrechen, weil er schon so damit überladen ist, Riesenzeilen anzuzeigen, seine internen Buffer nicht mehr klarkommen, das User-Interface einfriert und überhaupt generell alles ganz Schlimmes. Oh man, oh man, oh man, da ist der Microsoft-Internet nicht Explorer, sondern der Server, der Information-Server insofern besser ist.
Nee, der macht er nicht.
Bitte?
Das ist eine Feature vom Internet Explorer.
Nein, nein, das ist auch eine Feature vom Server, dass ein Mime-Type halt auch bekannt sein muss.
Ach so, muss, ok, ja, das meinste auch, ja. Das ist der Apache, die Default-Einstellung nicht richtig ist.
Genau, die Default-Einstellung, ich meine, wenn überhaupt eine Default, dann halt sowas wie Application Octet Stream, so nach dem Motto, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist, irgendein Programm mag das wissen, was es ist, aber für mich ist es einfach nur ein Octet Stream, also einfach nur Bites und nicht auch, das kenne ich jetzt nicht, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein Textdokument.
Ist das nicht aber so in derselben Denke, wie das Protokoll selber? Wenn du die Leute anguckst, siehst du, dass das Protokoll...
Ja, da sind wir jetzt wieder bei diesem UNIX und alles ist möglich.
Alles ist Text?
Ja, alles ist Text, alles kann darin abgebildet werden. Das ist furchtbar. Ist schlimm, ich will das nicht. Auf jeden Fall, WebDAV ist bloatet, aber flexibel und hat natürlich auch gleich viele Vorteile mit dem MIME-Type, mit dem sehr flexiblen Dateinamen sozusagen, den Ressourcen der Versionierung und auch der extremen Erweiterbarkeit, weil uns ja leicht vorstellbar, dass man in Zukunft halt weitere HTTP-Methoden einfach hinzufügt, die dann, was weiß ich, für welche Funktionalitäten implementieren. Und es zeigt sich halt schon, dass eben für solche Internet-Disk-Dienste das verwendet wird, anstatt dass man das bislang undokumentierte SMB nimmt, was verständlich ist, weil niemand kann das eigentlich richtig implementieren. Und aber auch nicht AFP, was zwar wohl dokumentiert ist, aber was ja auch einen extremen Aufwand erfordert. Weil gewisser Hinsicht ist ja WebDAV, wenn ich es richtig sehe, auch mit relativ wenig Code zu implementieren. Ich meine, es sind dann so sechs oder sieben verschiedene Methoden, die man implementieren muss und das war's eigentlich.
Das Wesentliche, was noch dazu kommt, was man jetzt nicht so sieht, ist das Brausen von Direktorys, weil das ja wegfällt. Normalerweise, wenn du über HTTP in der Direktorie braust, dann bekommst du ja von einem Web-Server so ein Direktorielisting in ASCII-Format. Also in ASCII, also in Unicode-Format, also im Textformat geliefert. Ja, aber das ist ein Web-DRV. Das ist ja auch dann nochmal institutionalisiert worden, dass man also wirklich auch eine Direktorie enumerieren kann, was eigentlich im HTTP-Browser-Umfeld nicht üblich ist. Man kann das ja nicht tun, außer man aufreift über diesen ASCII-Hack zu. Also das gute alte Weget, wenn das zum Beispiel im rekursiven Modus eine ganze Direktorierarchie downloaden muss, hofft, dass man dann indirekt entweder alle Links folgen kann oder wenn man ein Direktorielisting bekommt, dass er den Inhalt passen kann.
Das brauchen wir ja auch, sonst hätte man ja, wenn man so was mautet, keine Verzeichnisse.
Genau. Es geht nämlich über den getrennten neuen im WebDAV vorhandenen Animierungsmechanismus, um dann die ganzen Sachen anzugucken.
Ah ja, ok, verstehe. Darüber wird dann sozusagen das eigentliche Fallsystem abgebildet, die eigentliche Hierarchie.
Richtig.
Das heißt, man kann eigentlich so ein WebDAV-Server auch relativ leicht selbst schreiben? Gibt es denn irgendwelche nennenswerten Implementierungen? Also muss es immer gleich ein Apache mit dem Plugin sein? Oder gibt es auch leichtgewichtige WebDAV-Implementierungen? Ist da irgendetwas bekannt?
Nee. Also ich kenne da bisher eigentlich nur immer die großen Gewichte. Weil WebDAV wird eigentlich fast immer im Umfeld von richtigen fetten Servern eingesetzt. Wenn du zum Beispiel die kleinen Server siehst, die dann also speziell manche Sachen besonders gut können, wie dieser TH-TTP oder dieser Tiny-HTTP-Demon, die beschränken sich dann am meisten von den Features her, dass sie manchen ganz besonders gut schnell in Frast-EGI können und mit speziellen Interfaces spezielle dynamischen Seiten besonders gut ausliefern können. Das sind eigentlich Sonderkonstruktionen. Ich kenne da noch keine Sonderkonstruktionen für WebDAV.
Ich gucke hier gerade bei webdav.org gibt es in der Tat eine ganze Reihe von kleineren Projekten, die alle dieses und jenes implementieren, also Kleins, aber auch Server in verschiedenen Poemiersprachen. Solche Systeme wie Soap oder so haben dann auch entsprechende WebDAV Frontends. Für mich sieht es schon so aus, als ob man sagen kann, es bewegt sich dahin. Zumindest, wo es jetzt nicht wirklich um High-Performance-Zugriff auf Files geht, im eigentlichen Sinne, also wo man schnelle Files habe, sondern wo die Flexibilität und die Transparenz im Internet im Vordergrund steht.
Und der Benamensraum. Wichtig ist ja auch der sehr Benamensraum. Du hast ja im Fall der lokalen Mounts mit irgendwelchen Fallsystemen von irgendwelchen anderen Rechnern einen ganz anderen Namensraum, wie den Namensraum, den du über das aktuelle Web hast. WebDAV fügt sich da voll in den Namensraum des Web ein. Es wird über dieselben Mechanismen über Port 80 gemacht, ist deswegen transparent zu den eingebauten Firewall-Regeln. Auch noch so ein Aspekt. Ist direkt inline mit dem HTTPS, mit dem entsprechenden SSL, der ihr verheiratet. Zertifikate, Sicherheit, Verkryptete, Transfer aller Daten. Und den Namensraum, das wichtig ist, weil die Leute wissen, ich kann unter www.blafase.de oder so ähnlich noch in der Subdirektur so und so ein WebDAV-Fallsystem erreichen. So wird es ja dann auch angeboten. Irgendwo eine Subverzeichnung von einem eigentlichen Web-Server, der andere Sachen auch da bietet, dann gibt es dann plötzlich auch noch WebDAV-Verzeichnisse.
Auf jeden Fall wird klar, das eine oder andere wissen wir nicht, wenn dann jemand von den Hörern noch einen guten Tipp hat, so zum Thema performante kleine DAV-Server, die man mal eben irgendwie auf eine Maschine schmeißen kann. Das ist ja auch ganz interessant. Da sind wir auf jeden Fall für Tipps auch offen. An der Stelle schon mal auch der Hinweis auf unser Blog, blog.chaosradio.cccde, aber keine Angst, die Sendung ist jetzt noch nicht zu Ende, bevor ich das bloß unerwähnt lasse, schmeiße ich mir das doch hier lieber nochmal gleich in den Kanal. Obwohl wir jetzt aber eigentlich so mit dem Thema File, Zugriff über Protokolle, so ein bisschen, also ich bin jetzt ein bisschen ans Ende meiner Notizen und Fragen gekommen. Oder haben wir noch irgendeinen ganz grundlegenden Aspekt vernachlässigt, der vielleicht hier noch erwähnt gehört zu dem Thema?
Was man vielleicht noch erwähnen könnte, sind die verschiedenen Verhalten von Protokollen bezüglich Latenzen von dem unterliegenden Medien, was sie vertragen können. Zum Beispiel viele Protokolle im File-System, also AFP, sei es NFS oder auch ZIFFS, die haben verschiedene Eigenschaften, wie sie sich verhalten, wenn der unterliegende Medium langsamer wird und wenn der Roundtrip größer wird. Vielfach werden ja Betriebssystem-Calls abgebildet, wie zum Beispiel bei UNIX im NFS-Bereich ein Open Read, wo ein Name herausgefunden wird, eine Stadt, wo ich dann herausbekommen kann, was für Attribute der File hat. Und wenn ich iterativ durchs File-System durcharbeite, typischerweise unter UNIX ein Find, habe ich eine Unmenge von kleinen Calls, die abgesetzt werden von kleinen zum Server. Ich muss also immer unbedingt nachfragen. Ich weiterlesen im Vertrag zu Inhaltsverzeichnis, jeden einzelnen Pfeil in Stadt und so weiter. Nächste Direktorie anfahren, gibt es da irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, das zu komprimieren. Weil zum Beispiel auch eine TCP-Connection, wenn ich sie mit kleinen Datenmengen im Roundtrip verwende, nicht wirklich effizient ist über längere Strecken. Deswegen sind diese File-System-Protokolle auch meistens eher schlecht über lange Strecken zu verwenden, weil sobald dann die Läderinne ist, hackt das ganze User-Interface, weil die Inhalte von den Fenstern nicht richtig dargestellt werden können und dergleichen. Und da gibt es verschiedene Sachen. Also z.B. NFS ist da der wohl im Originalzustand mieseste Vertreter, der gar keine Attribute bei seinen Direkturalesen mittendringt, weil man kriegt doch den Namen. Was bräuchte Attribute? Kann nachfragen, wenn ich die Attribute haben will.
Da muss man jeden einzelnen auch noch mal fragen.
Genau, dann wurde das ein bisschen optimiert. NFS-Vorsorge 3 hat dann schon mal so einen erweiterten Retier bekommen, wo dann ein paar Attribute von einer Art Stadt mit hinten getockt wurde an den ganzen Fallnamen, dass man schon ein bisschen mehr erfahren hat, dass der Klein nicht automatisch nachfragen musste. Und NFS-V4 hat dann so ähnlich wie dann auch AFP und ZIFS die Möglichkeit, mehr Attribute schon von vornherein bei jedem Direktoriet Traversal nachzufragen. Das ist auch eine wichtige Sache, die man berücksichtigen muss, wenn man zum Beispiel über weite Entfernungen was macht.
Ich habe auch noch eine Frage, welche Attribute überhaupt so unterstützt werden. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass so bei Novell gab es irgendwie so ein Shitload von Millionen Zugriffsrechten und allen möglichen Optionen, die man noch drauf zugreifen kann.
Ja, das Zugriffsrechtsmodell ist ja auch sehr unterschiedlich. Also von wegen hat man Access-Kontrolllisten, hat man einfache User- und Group-basierende Zugriffsmodelle. Also das frühe AFP kam mit User- und Group-Zugriffsrechten, hinterher wurden dann ACLs nachimplementiert.
Das ist auch in 3.0 gekommen?
Das ist dann glaube ich auch in 3.1 gekommen. Da gab es dann auch Access-Kontrolllisten.
Wahrscheinlich parallel zur Einführung der ACLs in Mac OS X.
Ja, genau, das war parallel dazu. Und sowas gibt es dann auch, genauso natürlich auch im SMB-Fall, weil NT niemals so ein User-Gruppverzeichnis rechthast, immer ACLs. Und unter NFS wurde es dann nachträglich auch langsam implementiert, dass man das auch z.B. über ACLs hat, weil vielfach war ACL ja auch wieder ein Seitenbandprotokoll. Es gab dann so Sonderprotokolle, IBM hat sein eigenes ACL-Protokoll, SGR hat sein eigenes ACL-Protokoll seitwärts noch zum NFS gehabt, um an die Access-Kontrollisten anzukommen, wenn sie unterstützt waren im Betriebssystem.
Bietet denn da WebDAV irgendetwas an, in dem Zusammenhang? Kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern, dass da so ausufernde Benutzerrechte in irgendeiner Form abgebildet sind?
Ich glaube, die sind im Fallsystem gar nicht drin, im WebDAV. Das ist vielleicht auch ein Manko. Da wird also auf diese rechte Sache gar nicht so weit eingegangen.
Das wird halt irgendwie vom Server gehandhabt.
So ungefähr.
Die Frage ist, ob der Client da so viel darüber wissen muss eigentlich.
Das ist ja so, dass in dem normalen klassischen Fallsystem auch viel Administration vom Fallsystem selber aus gemacht wurde. Man hat einfach ein Infofeld über einen Ordner gemacht und hat dann gesagt, das ist jetzt mein Ordner, da hat der und der Zugriffsrechte drauf. So mache ich zum Beispiel auf dem Mac meine Dropbox. Ich gebe frei für jeden und riet nur für mich und dann kann da jeder was reintun, aber ich kann nur ganz was rausholen.
Das stimmt.
Und so waren dann einfach administrative Tätigkeiten auch einfach im ganz normalen Fallsystem-Fenster möglich. Oder ich kann zum Beispiel einfach einen Ordner jemandem anders schenken. Oder ich kann einer Gruppe Zugriffsrechte geben, wenn der mir gehört, der Ordner. Weil wenn mir der Ordner mir gehört, kann ich ihn um... kann ich die Rechte ändern.
Und Zugriffsrechte könnte man jetzt so bei WebDAV in dem Sinne gar nicht...
Bin mir jetzt nicht so im Klaren, wie es da noch funktioniert. Müsste man also offen halten, muss ich jetzt also sagen?
Naja, zumal wenn man jetzt hier so eine iDisc hat oder so, hier mal irgendwie auch mal einer draufklicken, da habe ich ja auch Zugriffsrechte in dem Sinne, oder? Hier ist noch ein kleines Schloss, was geklickt werden möchte und dann sieht mir das eigentlich so aus, als ob ich da so dieselbe Flexibilität habe wie mit den ACLs, aber das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen geraten. Tatsächlich, ich sagte mir gerade, ich hätte Custom Access, was immer das heißt im Markt. Also es scheint da irgendwie schon eine Möglichkeit geben, das zu machen. Da sind wir wieder unwissend und geben unser modernes Halbwissen Preis. Genau, man kann nicht alles wissen. Aber jetzt, von den Filesaber-Protokollen denke ich, das Kapitel können wir jetzt mal schließen. Wir sollten auch vielleicht langsam zum Ende der Sendung kommen. Aber ich weiß ja, dass du dich auch mit Printing auseinandergesetzt hast. Bei Mac war das ja recht verheiratet. Also das AFP, das Filing-Protokoll, hatte dann noch so sein Schwester-Protokoll, das APP? Genau, weil man nicht mehr PAP sagen kann. Printer-Access-Protokoll, war das jetzt irgendwie so, hatte das irgendwas miteinander wirklich auch zu tun?
Nein, gar nicht. Das war ein total separates Protokoll in der Applikationslehre von Mac. Wurde auch zwar über Apple Talk über dasselbe Mechanismus abgewickelt, aber waren getrennte Protokolle, wie man auch über TCPIP mal einen Port HTTP haben kann und einen anderen Port NFS. Eine vollkommen getrennte Geschichte. Aber es war schon früh ein Protokoll zum Drucker mit Feedback zu dem Zeitpunkt, als die meisten Druckerprotokolle noch durch ein unidirektionales Parallelport mit Druckersprachen und nicht mal zu der Drucker sagen konnten.
Es gab eigentlich keine Protokolle, keine Druckerprotokolle. Das Druckerprotokoll bestand darin, dass man die Datei über eine serielle oder parallele Schnittstelle rüber schickt. Oder eine serielle oder parallele Schnittstelle rüber schickt und fertig.
Und man hat gehofft, dass sie auch gedruckt hat.
Genau, und es gab noch nicht mal eine Fehlermeldung oder so.
Genau, und das PAP-Protokoll war von vornherein schon so designt, dass es Fehlermöglichkeiten gibt, dass es eine Statusinformation gibt, dass es einem beim Öffnen ein Mechanismus gibt, wie der Server eine Art Warteschlange etablieren kann mit vielen Clients. In dem man sicherstellt, dass also beim Öffnen zieht jeder Client schon damit bei, wie lange er schon wartet auf die Erbindung, dass er dann bei gleichzeitigen Öffnungsversuchen auf denselben Drucker entscheiden kann, wer am längsten gewartet hat, kann jetzt mal dran kommen. Das sozusagen in einem Nicht-Spuler- Umgebung, wo sozusagen jeder Konkurrent auf denselbe Drucker-Resource zugreift, dass der Drucker selber entscheiden kann. Der hat am längsten gewartet, der kommt als erstes dran mit seinem Druckjob. Und gleichzeitig sieht man auch ständig in der McIntosh Druckdialogbox wurde auch ständig der Status, der in dem PAP-Protokoll rückermittelt wurde. Da gab es die Möglichkeit, also diesen Status abzufragen, den aktuellen Status, also Out of Band, außerhalb des normalen Druckkanals, wo die Daten hin und her gingen, der bidirektional war, in beide Richtungen, wurde dann der Status ständig übergeben und dann wurde auch in diesem Status auch was ausgegeben, was Druck gerade tut. Das war dann zum Beispiel informativ, dass der Benutzer sehen konnte, was er machen konnte. Und das war ja von vorne rein eigentlich im Wesentlichen Postscript gewesen, was gemacht wurde über diese Printer-Access-Protokoll-Geschichten. Und deswegen wurde zum Beispiel auch sowas gemacht wie Font-Queries. Es wurde zum Beispiel Postscript drüber geladen.
Man könnte sagen, welche Fonts hast du denn eigentlich?
Genau, da wurde ein kleines Postscript-Programm drüber geschickt und dieses Postscript-Programm ermittelt zum Beispiel die aktuell im Drucker installierte Font-Liste und die war dann über dem Rückkanal sichtbar. Man musste also nicht administrativ vom Benutzer her sagen, ich habe dem Drucker die und die Fonts runtergeladen. Nein, das konnte das Programm selber rausfinden.
Und konnte dann dynamisch einfach die Fonts, die fehlten, einfach hinterher schmeißen.
Genau, das wurde ja dann bei Macintosh auch so gemacht, dass also diese Fonts dann gemanagt wurden, explizit in der Connection.
Ah ja, drucken. Man konnte das immer das Tolle am Mac. Ich glaube, das ist das, was mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, dass man einfach druckte, indem man einfach druckte. Man druckte einfach und es druckte. Es gab kein...
Es druckt nicht, gibt es nicht.
Das gab es einfach nicht. Es druckte einfach immer. Und ich finde, die Experience ist insofern ehrlich gesagt mit Mac OS X schlechter geworden. Ja, also das ist einfach mein Gefühl nicht da, wo es vor 15 Jahren schon mal war. Was ich auch, was meine Missbedingungen findet und was ich auch nicht so richtig verstehe. Weil es ist strange, was da so die Gründe sind. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass Apple keine Drucker mehr baut.
Vermute ich mal.
Ja, also da hat er ja diese, erstmal diese Abhängigkeit von den Treibern und dann irgendwie auch alle möglichen Arten und Weisen, wie Drucken geht. Ich meine, man ging ja dann in zunehmendem Maße über die Druckerübertragung. Ich meine, es gab ja dann LPR, das Druckerprotokoll, was ja unter UNIX verbreitet war.
Das ist aber dasselbe wie parallel das Port, Druck und Vergiss.
Genau.
Ohne Feedback, ohne alles.
Es ist eigentlich nichts anderes als ein Port, wo man die Daten reinschmeißt und dann macht man wieder zu, oder? Da gibt es keinerlei irgendwie Diskussion.
Eine Warteschlange gibt es noch. Es ist aber so, dass man also nichts irgendwie, es ist ja eigentlich nur eine Kommunikation gewesen zwischen zwei Line-Printer-Demons, LPDs, die auf verschiedenen Rechnern liefen und die sich gegenseitig die Spult-Qs zugeschaufelt haben. Es wurde also immer angenommen, dass beide Rechner die Dateien komplett vorher im vorderen Tag haben, weil zum Beispiel die es protokoll-impliziert enthält, ich möchte vorher wissen, wie viel Bites ich habe. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel in einer Applikation bin, die zum Beispiel eine Unmenge Postscript generiert, dann muss ich zwangsweise bei dem LPD-Protokoll die Datei vorher abspeichern, damit ich weiß hinterher, wie viel ich übertrage, weil als allererstes fragt mich das LPD-Protokoll, wie viel Bites hättest du denn, wie viel Bites wollen sie mir denn senden?
Warum?
Die wollten vorher den Spool-Space restrieren, also wie viel Spool-Space diese Spool-Partition jeweils hat.
Na ja, ist ja ein heeres Ziel.
Ja, das Management von Disk-Space steckt da wohl dahinter. Oh ja, ich hab da keine Anekdote zwischendurch, weil wir auch in dem Druckversuchen mit verschiedenen Postscript-Druckern, Fotosatz-Belichtern und dergleichen viele Experimente machen mussten und vielfach auch komische Sachen gesehen haben. Hab ich dann mal diese mehr Gigabyte Postscript-Datei gesehen, wo dann jemand gesagt hat, das druckt nicht auf seinen Belichter. Diese riesige Postscript-Datei resultierte aus einem, also auf einem Page-Layout-Programm. Ich weiß nicht, welches Page-Layout-Programm das momentan war, aber die war gigantisch groß. Das war eigentlich nur eine kleine Vereinszeitung, aber das Ding war einfach riesig. Der resultierende Fall war irgendwie die 2 GB Postscript. Damals halt ein echt monumentales Dokument.
Auch für heutige Zeiten, also 2 GB Druckdatei, wüsste ich nicht so richtig.
Genau. Und der Trick bei der Datei war der gewesen, dass der Mensch wohl seit es diesen Verein gab, das wohl schon etliche Jahre war, in seinem Publikationsprogramm immer gesagt hat, wenn eine neue Vereinszeitung ansteigt. Ich muss erstmal eine neue weiße Schicht über alles drüber weglegen, was vorher war. Hat dann aber alles weiß markiert und hat dann drauf die neue Seite aufgebaut.
Das heißt, jede Vereinszeitung wird dich literally auf den anderen draufgedockt.
Genau. Und immer nur über weiß drüber weglegen, das gibt es auch noch mal.
Okay, super. Unglaublich. Verstehe. Die war groß. Aber zurück zu den Protokollen. Es gibt ja auch da, gibt es in der SMB-Welt dann auch noch das entsprechende Äquivalent?
Das ganze Management wird über das RPC-Mechanismus abgewickelt. Im SMB ist ja inline, wie ich vorhin erwähnte, ein RPC-Mechanismus. Das gesamte Print-Spool-System basiert darauf, dass es da mit drinne ist. Komplett. Im Pipe-Protokoll.
Ach, im SMB. Also nicht nur diese Nebenspipes, sondern auch noch das Drucken ist alles mit drin. Warum?
Weil es das einfachste Weg, zwischen zwei Rechnern zu kommunizieren mit diesen Nebenspipes, das ist einfacher, die beiden Spool-Demos miteinander zu verbinden.
Server-Message-Block. Das ist nicht ein Filesystem-Protokoll, sondern es ist ein Computer-Verbindungs-Protokoll.
Impezit über diese Nebenspipes-Geschichte ist es auch gleichzeitig ein Remote-Protokoll-Mechanismus und Programm-zu-Programm-Rede-Mechanismus.
Mehr so eine Betriebssystembrücke. Das heißt, Drucken ist auch noch mit drin und wie bildet sich das dann ab? Das heißt, jetzt verstehe ich auch warum. Das heißt, dieses Browsing, was wir schon hatten, wo diese Ressourcen angezeigt werden, zeigt halt nicht nur Fallsystem-Ressourcen an, sondern auch Drucker-Ressourcen. Auch noch andere Ressourcen?
Ja, es gibt mehrere, aber die sind neuerdings auch diese... Also, wenn das im Browser vom Windows, der mischt da ja eine ganze Menge Ressourcen zusammen. Der mischt ja auch noch die UPNP-Ressourcen von gefundenen Routern mit rein und angeschlossene andere Geräte, die er sonst noch finden kann. Da gibt es eine ganze Ecke Sideband-Protokolle, die da verwendet werden. Das ist also beliebig erweiterbar. Das ist ja auch mit dem Plug-In-Mechanismus der inneren Windows-Betriebssystem verwendet werden beliebig anderweitig erweiterbar.
Aber üblicherweise ist es Drucken und Pfeilsystem plus dieses Namepipe-Geschichte, was wir schon vorhin...
Also, von Microsoft selbst wird es intensiv für administrative Zecke verwendet. Dieses ganze Windows-Management-Interface wird darüber abgebildet. Das Instrumentieren des Betriebssystems, das man abfragen kann, wie Performance-Counter und die ganzen Kram, wird alles darüber abgewickelt.
Verstehe. Und was zeichnet sich jetzt ab? Eigentlich so im Druckbereich, wurde dann das IPP-Protokoll spezifiziert, das Internet-Printing-Protokoll. Ist das auch bekannt?
Ja, das wird verwendet ja zum Beispiel auch bei dem CUBS. Das ist ja als beliebter Implementator, das ja auch innerhalb des Mac-Betriebs-Systems verwendet wird.
Genau.
Auf dem Podset 631, wo es immer drauf ist.
Apple hat sich sogar den Programmierer noch dazu geschnappt.
Genau. Aber IPP war ja von vornherein schon als Spezifikation von mehreren Leuten, also von mehreren Firmen, entwickelt worden, mal um das Möglichkeit, Cross-Plattformen zu drucken.
Die auch wissen, was sie tun?
Ja, das Protokoll ist gut ausgedacht. Das fängt von vornherein an, dass es mit SSL funktioniert, Verschlüsselung und Authentisierung. Also es ist ähnlich angelegt, würde ich fast sagen, wie WebDAV, es hat also alles mögliche drinne.
Ist aber jetzt nicht auf HTTP basierend?
Doch. Ist es? Ja, das IPP-Port, also man sagt ja, das Internet Printing ist ja IPP-Doppelpunkt, das Protokoll. Wenn du aber Internet für die Kommunikation in der Art HTTP...
Ah, das heißt auch IPP.
Nur ein anderes Port.
Verstehe.
Deswegen kannst du dir jeden Kubserver IPP über das Port 631 lokal ansprechen und da findest du einen Web-Server. Weil wenn du in deinem Web-Browser deinen localhost doppelt Punkt 631 eingibst...
Dann spreche ich tatsächlich IPP sozusagen.
Ja, dann sprichst du mit dem IPP-Server in deiner Maschine, die dir den Print-Server darstellt.
Der ja auch in der Lage ist mir......
eine Webpage darzustellen von dem aktuellen Zustand des Drucksystems.
Jetzt klackert auch wieder mal das eine oder andere Rädchen im Kopf.
Also IPP kann man so sehen als Drucken, wie das WebDAV in Erweiterung ist.
Man hat es dann auch die Fähigkeiten von PAP vollständig übernommen. Also kann man auch Fonts aushandeln. Ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich unabhängig von Postscript. PAP war schon auch ein bisschen an Postscript gebunden.
Ja, man ist nicht ganz dasselbe. Man kann viele Sachen aushandeln, aber die direkten Status- und Feedback-Möglichkeiten sind reduziert, weil es eigentlich immer davon ausgesagen wird, dass die Ressorts, die IPP sprechen kann, auch einen Spooler hat. Es wird zum Beispiel nicht erwartet, dass man mit einem Gerätsprecher, der lange Arbeitszeiten hat, das PAP hat ja direkt die Möglichkeit, dass man fast schon die Räder in dem Belichter hat drehen, sich sehen, dass der Belichter sagen könnte, ich mache jetzt dieses, ich habe jetzt den Belichter angeworfen, ich habe jetzt die Entwicklungsstattung angeworfen und diese Startesachen. Solche device-spezifische Strings, die rüber kommen, konnten das jetzt eigentlich im IPP nicht so vorgesehen, weil angenommen wird, auch der File wird einfach da gespoolt.
Ok, ok, auch ein Faxgerät kann mittlerweile zwischenspeichern.
Ja, also das PAP-Protokoll ist der Ansicht da mehr so der Gedanke gewesen, ich will direkt den Status verfolgen, wie das Gerät jetzt gerade arbeitet. Also würde ich beim Faxgerät jetzt sozusagen auf meinem Rechner sehen wollen, wie er gerade wählt. Ich mache gerade den vierten Wählversuch, um die...
Naja, also ich fände das in der Tat interessant, um ehrlich zu sein, weil gerade bei Fax geht echt immer so eine Menge schief, nicht? Was weiß ich, dann ist es mal wieder keine Fax-Nummer, sondern eine Hasse.
Ein Voice-Dranne, ne?
Voice-Dranne oder sonst irgendeine bekloppte Weiterleitung, so.
Naja, ein direkter Feedback ist leider nicht so drin. Ich glaube, Apple war damals mit ihrem Protokoll, mit dem direkten Feedback, mit dem direkten Trending sehr weit. Das ist leider...
Apple war bei IPP nicht beteiligt?
Doch, auch.
Ja, aber das haben sie nicht durchbekommen, oder?
Ich war bei diesen Beschränkungen nicht dabei. Ich weiß nicht, welche Politik da gelaufen ist.
Okay, aber IPP taugt an sich auch für Fax und wird auch von Fax-Devices verwendet.
Richtig, weil es alles ist Beschreibung. Es gibt fast beliebige Job-Tickets, die jedem Job dabei geben, was für ein Processing da ist. Es gibt, glaube ich, Hersteller, die Job-Tickets, die dann bei IPP mit übergeben werden, so etwas Ansteuern, so etwas Komplexes, wie so eine ganze Schneidestraße, die hinterher komplette Briefumschläge macht. Die Einpackinstruktionen können auch mit hinten in den Job-Tickets drin sein. Es gibt da beliebig Metadaten für Job-Tickets, die man mitgeben kann.
Ich wollte das jetzt gar nicht so vertiefen, aber jetzt finde ich das ja doch ganz interessant. Das heißt, IPP ist schon eigentlich auch das Protokoll, was man so verwenden wollen würde. Und es wäre eigentlich auch sinnvoll, dass Drucker das selbst sprechen. Und die meisten tun es.
Es gibt heutzutage, die netzwerkfähigen Drucker können auch meistens IPP mit.
Mal gucken, ob man da das auch kann. Und wenn ich dann aber über IPP was schicken will, brauche ich natürlich auch einen IPP-fähigen Client, der eigentlich überall heute drin ist. Der heute drin ist? In dem Standard-Drucksystem, das das Betriebssystem an sich bereitstellt.
Wenn du unter UNIX einen CUBS installiert hast, bist du automatisch IPP-fähig. Mac kommt mit CUBS mit, ist deswegen IPP-fähig. Und Windows kann das auch schon eine lange Zeit.
Gut, aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich ein Programm angenommen, ich habe jetzt so ein Druck-Environment nicht, aber ich weiß, da ist jetzt ein IPP-Drucker und ich würde da jetzt einfach gerne mal eine Seite ausgeben. Sagen wir, ich habe irgendein Embedded-Device.
Dann ist IPP wohl auch noch eine gute Wahl, weil das ist, glaube ich, meines, wie ich es gesehen habe, simpel genug, da schnell einen Druckstopp zusammenzustellen.
Was muss man dann da irgendwie so im Wesentlichen tun als Abstration?
HTTP-Protokoll. Man muss dem Dick einen Image-Type mitgeben und dem Server auch hoffen, dass er diesen Image-Type verwandeln kann.
Ach so, das heißt, ich kann sagen, ich poste da einfach...
Application slash Postscript und dann hörst du durch.
Welche Methode nimmt er dann?
Kein Print.
Ah, das heißt, ich kann PNG nehmen.
Mime-Type. Das Wesentliche dreht sich dabei auch beim IPP um Mime-Types.
Das heißt, ich kann einfach per IPP drucken, indem ich sage, hallo, hier, ich putte mal ein PNG auf dich.
Genau, und der Drucker muss dann sehen, was er will. Entweder er kann das drucken, weil er es nicht versteht, weil die in Mime-Type nicht verstehen, oder er keine entsprechenden Konvertierungsfilter installiert hat, die es können, oder er akzeptiert es.
Okay, also so PNG dürfte er ja schon ein bisschen Verbreitung gefunden haben, aber der eine oder andere kann dann wahrscheinlich auch schon PDF, oder?
Genau.
Was weiß ich, was da irgendwie ist. Das heißt, das müsste man sich dann in der Spezifikation anschauen, oder kann man sich über IPP auch sagen lassen, was er kann?
Ups, da gab es was, aber ich bin nicht für sicher. Da gab es, glaube ich, eine Numerierungsmöglichkeit, dass man herausfinden kann, welche Mimetimes unterstützt werden von einem Gerät. Mir ist ganz dunkel noch was da hängen geblieben.
Müsste man mal die Mainpage durchlesen, bzw. die Dokumentation. Ist ein richtiger Internet-Standard?
Ja, gibt es also richtig eine Organisation, die auch die entsprechenden Spezifikationen zum Downloaden anbietet. Ich kann mich in den Sinn mal die etwas umfangreiche Spezifikation angelesen zu haben.
War schon etwas schwerer, ja.
Ja, schon etwas. Eine von den schwergewichtigeren Dokumentationen.
Gut, halten wir fest. Das Internet mausert sich und hat jetzt auch die alten Domänen des lokalen Netzwerks, Filesharing und auch Printer-Access langsam, aber sicher im Blick.
Ja, WebDAV und IPP sind echte.
WebDAV und IPP und letzten Endes ist es halt auch nur Http. Was da gesprochen wird, ist in einer Lage, in zunehmendem Maße das, was man halt lokal mit den anderen Protokollen gemacht hat, in sich aufzunehmen. Andererseits werden wir wahrscheinlich noch ziemlich lange mit SMB und mit AFP auch leben müssen oder auch NFS. Ich hab ja ganz gute Erfahrungen gemacht mit AFP, das konnte schon immer so viel. SMB ist halt einfach lange Zeit wirklich sehr anstrengend gewesen, weil dieses ganze Re-Engineering immer noch voranschritt und dadurch, dass man eben immer mal wieder auf Geräte getroffen hat, die andere Auffassung darüber hatten, wie SMB eigentlich wirklich funktioniert, war es schwierig. Gerade diese extrem populären Network, wie nennt man sie es noch gleich, die Network Enable Storage Sachen. Das ist ja total sinnvoll, man hat da einfach mal so eine Platte, da steckt man einfach ein Ethernet-Kabel rein, irgendwann gibt es die auch mit WLAN, und dann schert das halt einfach mal falsch. Und der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner ist halt SMB, aber genau an der Stelle rennt man dann halt immer wieder in diese Kompatibilitätsissues rein, ist natürlich doof. Eigentlich will man ein NAS haben, was einfach WebDAV spricht, oder?
Vielleicht, aber wie machst du denn die Administration? Die ist dann ja bei WebDAV wahrscheinlich out of band. Oder willst du den HTTP-Content?
Die Administration von was? Von dem Teil? Na, über Web?
Über Web, über Webseiten.
Warum nicht?
Ja.
Das sind auch eigentlich nur Passwörter. Das funktioniert wahrscheinlich auch bei den anderen Devices derzeit nicht anders. Nur das Sharing an sich funktioniert eben dann eben über SMB und eben nicht über WebDAV, was natürlich ganz sinnvoll wäre. Aber WebDAV ist sowohl bei Mac als auch bei Windows mit drin. Und es gibt auch Clients für Linux und alle anderen Systeme.
Funktionieren die auch gut?
Ich hab sie ehrlich gesagt nie verwendet. Ich bin auch kein e-Disc-Fan.
Also, auch an der Stelle gibt es hier wieder Potenzial für die Zuhörer, sich hier mit ins Gespräch einzubringen. Das wird jetzt langsam zu Ende führen werden, hier ins Uhr. Vielen Dank für die ausführlichen Erläuterungen. Zeit für mich, auch mal wieder zusammenzufassen, welche Kommunikationskanäle wir so in die andere Richtung anbieten. Nicht nur, dass ihr hier die ganze Zeit zuhören müsst. Nein, ihr könnt euch auch melden bei uns. E-Mails schicken, chaosradio.ccc.de oder noch sehr viel beliebter, bei mir zumindest, die Kommentare im Blog. Es gibt zu jeder Sendung einen Blogpost, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Dort wird auch Jens Uwe hoffentlich in der nächsten Zeit ein bisschen mitlesen. Und wenn noch mal spezifische Fragen zu den Protokollen kommen, die wir hier besprochen haben, oder was weiß ich, auch zur Entstehungsgeschichte des Internets, was wir ja auch am Anfang noch tangiert haben, denke ich mal, wenn wir da auch drauf eingehen können. Stimmt's? Auf jeden Fall. Gut, haben wir noch irgendeine Botschaft für die Welt, die wir noch unbedingt rausbringen müssen, bevor wir hier Tschüss sagen?
Ich glaube ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht mehr. Also sagen wir mal ganz ordentlich Tschüss. Und bis bald hier wieder auf dem Kanal bei Chaos Radio Express.